This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by stamps.com
if you go to stamps.com and click on the upper lip,
there's a photograph of an old school microphone.
You know the kind that everybody likes to use in photographs.
Nobody likes to use those stupid things in practice because they suck,
but for whatever reason there's a certain piece of nostalgia that's connected to
one of those old school microphones like the birth of the beast,
like that's,
that's,
that's the origin of it.
So for whatever talking into a microphone,
people love that,
but click on that thing.
It's an icon and enter in the code word j r e just for Joe Rogan experience and
you will get $110 bonus offer includes a digital scale and up to $55 free
postage.
stamps.com is an awesome thing to have if you are running a personal business.
If you have a small business and you work for yourself and maybe you're an
artist,
maybe you send things online.
Going to the post office is a huge drag for people.
And with something like stamps.com you can buy and print official us postage
using your own computer and printer.
Uh,
if you,
uh,
by any of Brian's a kitty cat tee shirts,
those death squad shirts,
death squad.tv,
he sends every,
all this stuff for like anything.
He sells bumper stickers,
tee shirts,
all that stuff goes through stamps.com and he used to have to do it at the going
to the post office and waiting in line.
It's a huge pain in the ass.
So it's really easy.
You do it all on your,
your own home computer.
You have a digital scale,
you weigh everything out,
but the postage on it,
mailman picks it up.
Boom,
you're done.
And again,
use the code word j,
r e and you'll save yourself some cash.
We're also brought to you by hover.
Hover is a domain name company that's owned by the same people that own Tang and
you know how much we love them.
Um,
hover has the same sort of principles.
Hover is a really easy website to use.
Very intuitive.
I actually have domains that I have personally registered through hover,
so I have actual experience doing it.
And if a monkey like me can pull it off with no hitches,
you can't too.
They also offer good stuff like they give you free things like,
uh,
who is domain name.
Um,
I identity guard where your anonymity,
so you don't have to,
um,
the actual words privacy who has domain name privacy.
But it's,
that's basically what it is like.
So if you have some freaky website and you don't want people to know where you
live,
which is probably a good idea,
uh,
they will do that for free.
Whereas other companies,
uh,
who is domain named privacy is actually something that you have to pay for it,
which is kind of silly.
If you go to hover.com forward slash Rogan,
you will save 10% off your domain name registrations.
All right,
to go there,
you're freaks.
And we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com as always.
Um,
I've always searched for a way to describe what a on it's supposed to be and uh,
it's,
it's like a human performance website.
What we sell is all stuff that we find to be beneficial,
whether it's for fitness,
like a kettle bells and battle ropes and weight vests and medicine balls and
Chin up bars and all sorts of things that I think are very beneficial for,
for,
for fitness to dictate your body in shape,
to do things to foods like hemp protein powder and mall walnut,
almond cashew butter.
We,
we try to just sell you a bunch of healthy shit like whatever hemp protein bars,
which are really delicious and nutrient dense.
And I think,
um,
the idea behind the company is just sell shit that you would use Michelle sell
shit that you would,
you would buy and you would use.
And a,
that's essentially what it is.
If you use a code name Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements seating that quick and get through
that shit,
Jamie.
Oh,
that was quick.
That was,
that was like professional.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
Graham Hancock is here and,
uh,
I can't tell you how fucking pumped I am to talk to you sir.
And Cue the music.
Let's get this party rolling.
Well,
good experience
Graham Hancock.
Alright,
sorry.
Just
fine.
You've,
um,
you've kicked the green bench.
Yes.
After a 24 year intense relationship with the,
uh,
the green goddess or the Green Bitch,
depending on what mood she's in,
I had to stop.
Um,
and uh,
I've come in for some,
I've commenced for some,
for some criticism for this and that.
And,
and I feel it's important to say that,
uh,
I hugely value and a love cannabis.
I think it's a wonderful herbal ally and I think that,
I don't think that I would ever have written my books off historical mystery if
I had not encountered cannabis rather late in life.
I did not smoke any dope until I was 37 years old and I'm now 62 wire and,
uh,
roughly rather by the age of 38.
That's when I started getting into historical mysteries or that it was all,
of course it's total stoner stuff.
Before that it was all carried,
the fairs,
you know,
so,
but suddenly something opened up for me and I'm very,
and I'm very grateful to the herb for that.
And initially my real,
I again,
I need to emphasize this.
I think the problem I eventually ended up having with cannabis,
it's not the fault of cannabis,
it's the fault of Graham Hancock.
I think my relationship became abusive with the herb.
It was not initially.
Initially it was something I would do evenings and weekends.
I would not try to write while I was actually stoned.
I would do my days
work and then chill out in the evening with a pipe or a joint.
That was,
that was how it was for me for quite awhile.
And I went through my first big historical mystery book,
the sign and the seal,
uh,
which was published in 1992 with that pattern.
In other words that I would be,
I would be smoking only after I down tools at the end of the evening.
And I was ready to chill.
Um,
and that worked fine.
But then when I started,
when I started writing fingerprints of the gods,
which was the biggest book I've,
I've ever done,
a 5 million copy bestseller all around the world,
when I started writing that I thought,
I'll experiment.
Let's see if I can be stoned and right.
And I discovered that I could,
I couldn't be started right.
And I like being stuck so much that in a way it,
it,
it urged me to just write all the time,
you know,
because then I had this,
I had this incredibly good reason to be stoned all the time.
And um,
it took away all the physical boredom of sitting there in my chair in front of
my computer screen,
just everything went away.
And I went into,
drifted into this space where I could explore ideas and manifest those ideas
down,
down on the page.
And I literally,
that's when I began what was to become ultimately an abusive relationship with
cannabis,
which I would fire up in those days,
might my joint or my pipe at a nine or 10 in the morning.
And I would,
I'm a hard worker.
I work 16 hours a day,
very often when I'm writing.
So come two o'clock the next morning,
I'd still be there smoking away.
Um,
and as the years went by,
this became a permanent daily pattern for me.
Whether I was writing or not,
I would be stoned from the moment I got up until the moment I went to bed.
And most people who came by my house or talk to me on the phone,
they would have had absolutely no idea because I was,
I was completely in control.
I didn't seem hi,
I could hold a rational conversation.
I was,
I was just fine.
Um,
and I've just felt,
I just felt really good.
And this is how it went on for many years.
Uh,
later on about in the early [inaudible] 2005,
actually,
I think perhaps a little earlier,
one of my kids told me that,
you know,
this stuff,
this smoke is,
you don't need to have combustion products.
Why don't you use a vaporizer?
So I bought myself a volcano
on the Internet and,
and um,
and then I heard that the British government was going to ban the use of ban all
peripherals.
So I bought myself two more volcanoes.
Volcanoes are quite expensive,
but that shows how dedicated I was covering your bases.
I had to make sure that I covered my bases.
Um,
and then I would be vaporizing from nine in the morning until two o'clock the
next morning,
seven days a weekend and increasingly strong strains.
And this is one thing that I would say if we lived in a regime and irrational
regime where there was no attempt by the government to police our states of
consciousness,
we could have much more choice in the kind of cannabis we get hold of for,
I would have liked to have canvas with much more CBD and maybe less THC with the
varieties I were smoking were very,
very THC,
THC,
uh,
loaded.
What's the difference in effect?
Well,
okay.
I mean the,
it depends how much you buy into the research on this,
but,
but the law,
a lot of good science has been done.
And the suggestion is that THC can promote a,
or reveal.
I don't want to see,
I don't want to blame the herb.
Anything I,
it can reveal certain psychotic tendencies in oneself.
And this is the well known paranoia,
which,
which uh,
many people associate with,
with smoking cannabis.
The CBD is an antipsychotic agent.
So the natural herb is balanced with CBD and THC and,
and it looks after you very well,
but where are we going into intensive breeding of the herb,
focusing on the element that makes you really high,
which is the THC.
Then we get,
uh,
get a herb that is somewhat unbalanced as a result of the interference of a,
of,
of humanity and,
and,
but you get more bang for your buck.
You know,
that's a very,
that's a very strong herb.
And I began to like a particular variety called cheese.
I think it's called cheese because it smells like,
you know,
old socks or,
or,
um,
Stilton you know,
like a blue cheese.
And a,
I found a grower who lived local to me who was just had an amazing green fingers
and,
and I would buy from him and,
um,
and I would sometimes have,
you know,
five or six ounces of the herb in my house cause I was blazing through this
stuff at the vendors at a tremendous rate.
That's enough to you where you could get in trouble for it.
So that's where the paranoia starts to become legitimate,
you know,
because actually they can not,
they can break down your door and they can confiscate your home and take away
your liberty and fuck you up forever.
You know,
they can do that.
And,
and so every time I heard a ring at the door or,
you know,
a car came up the street,
I would,
you know,
get,
get paranoid.
So that was high and I was high paranoid when you were a high,
well,
this is one of the reasons why,
um,
look,
what happened to me was that run about 2003,
I started for reasons of research initially,
uh,
working with Iowa Osca the,
the vine of souls.
This is the,
the powerful psychedelic brew,
which has been consumed by shamanistic cultures in the Amazon for thousands and
thousands of years.
And it's not called the vine of souls for nothing.
It's a,
uh,
it's a,
it's an extraordinary portal into other realms.
And,
and in some ways those realms are associated with death and perhaps sort of what
waits for us after death.
Nobody knows the answer to that.
But in [inaudible] you have certain experiences relating to that.
And right from the beginning when I started to drink Iowasca,
I mean this sounds nuts to anybody who hasn't done DMT or who hasn't drunk
Iowasca but you do meet intelligent entities and more and more around the world,
people drinking Iowasca I'm meeting this goddess figure.
She might appear as a serpent.
She might appear as a woman.
She might appear as some kind of panther or Jaguar,
a very powerful,
tough love kind of lady who reveals to you the truth about yourself and just
says,
you know,
you fucking deal with it cause that's how you are.
And what the truth that was revealed to me from quite early on was my
relationship with cannabis and got out of balance and I needed to get it back
into balance.
And of course I ignored those messages completely because I was so,
I was so much in love with my cannabis relationship that my wife said that
really it was like a head of mistress.
You know,
who I spent all my time with was the cat was the cannabis rather than rather
than her.
And this went on for many,
many years now the paranoia aspect,
okay,
I'm going to bare my heart here.
And you know,
I believe in being honest,
the paranoia aspect began to affect my relationship with my beloved partner,
Santa who I just love from the bottom of my heart.
And she is the best,
the most,
the most pure hearted,
generous,
spirited,
loving lady.
It's possible,
possible to imagine,
but I started to develop all kinds of suspicions about her,
which were completely groundless.
I started to imagine all sorts of stuff we're going on and then I started to act
up,
act towards her as though those suspicions were real.
And all of this was also related to my consumption of cannabis.
It was not caused by my consumption of cannabis.
I think this is a latent aspect of my own personality.
It was being revealed by this over abuse of,
of the,
of the cannabis herb and,
and therefore I was making my beautiful partner's life,
a misery sometimes,
not every day,
but sometimes,
and she was patiently putting up with this,
but she was suffering and we went down to Brazil in October,
2011 and if I had been told when we got on that plane and went down to Brazil,
that when I came back two weeks later,
I would probably never smoked cannabis again.
I would have laughed in the face of the person who told me that.
But the encounters that I had with the spirit of Iowasca,
whatever that is,
I'm willing to accept that there is no spirit of Iowasca,
that it's all something we generate out of our brains,
but for me,
she manifests as a re like a goddess and the encounters I had with that,
and I do think she's real,
that's just my personal belief system and those encounters that I had were
incredibly powerful and she took me to a place that was something like hell and
she took me to a place that was something like the judgment scene in the ancient
Egyptian religion.
Now the judgment scene is a place where your heart is weighed in the scales
against the feather of truth and harmony and cosmic justice,
and you do not want your heart to be heavy in those skills.
You want to be able to look back on your life and say,
I did good.
I did not add to the misery in the world.
I did something worthwhile with this incredible gift of life that the gave me
and I,
and,
and everything you've done every second,
every minute of your life is completely transparent.
Every thought,
every action,
everything you did from the moment that you became conscious until the moment of
your death is laid out before you.
And there's no hiding from it.
Like we great at creating illusions about our own behavior and persuading
ourselves that we're behaving just fine in the judgment hall of Osiris,
which is also called the hall of mark,
where the scene takes place.
All of that stripped away and you confront the truth.
And I was put there and I confronted the truth about myself and I saw the way
that I was behaving towards my partner and,
and,
and I was shown that this had to stop otherwise,
otherwise I was going to pay a huge price for it.
Um,
it,
I,
I had a series of terrifying,
terrifying experiences,
which my partner saw science I've shared with me because we were drinking Iowa,
get together and at a certain point entities came to her and,
and she had the experience of her heart being pulled out of her chest and the
entity said to her,
and she thought she was going to die and the entity said to her,
we're going to do this to you to teach grammar lesson.
And Santa's communicated that to me.
And I would rank that as probably the single most terrifying night of my entire
life.
And I've had some terrifying nights that was just absolutely scared,
rigid.
And I,
and I came out of that with,
uh,
a feeling,
a very clear feeling in a,
in Iowa we have sharings the next day after you've drunk the brew,
you share with the rest of the group that you've drunk with the experiences you
had the night before,
as much as you want to share.
And what I shared,
because I still didn't believe that I could stop smoking cannabis.
What I shared was that I was going to change my relationship with cannabis and,
and to get to a place where cannabis was serving me again rather than me serving
her.
Um,
and,
and that's what I believed.
But when I got back to England,
long flight,
what's the first thing I do?
I get out my vaporizer,
get out of my stash,
fire up the vaporizer and fill an ice bag of,
of the vapor.
He says,
warn us to articulate.
Well,
I miss it.
You know,
this was,
there would be,
cannabis is such a beautiful sensual ally if she's used.
Right.
So do you think it's just an imbalance issue with the CBD THC ratio?
We'll let me just,
let me just finish with what,
with what happened to me.
So I fill up the bag and I'm down there in my basement and I take the first and
I take the first draw and I'm suddenly filled with the most intense feelings of
horror and loading.
And it is exactly like I'm back in that space that ask it took me to,
and I try a second puff and I can't do it.
I physically could not continue.
I knew that I just,
I just could not continue.
I expressed the vapor out of the bag,
like crumpled up the bag.
I put it away and the next day I got rid of several ounces of cannabis and I
know,
I know it's terrible.
It's a terrible thing to do,
but,
but for me it was the right thing to do.
24 years,
nonstop relationship with cannabis,
definitely abusing the herb.
I had got to the point where the only rational course of action was what I was
shown in Iowasca,
which was to stop.
And I don't know whether it was because there was way too much THC and not
enough CBD or whether it was just me not being responsible for my own behavior.
I go,
I go around,
you know,
saying that I believe in adult responsibility and I do,
but I don't think I was being responsible.
I don't think I was using the herb in a responsible way.
I don't think I was using it in a respectful way and I paid a price for that.
Well,
that's very honest and forthcoming of you to,
to talk about it and it's very uncomfortable for people to,
uh,
to discuss mistakes they've made or passive gone down that they didn't,
for whatever reason,
they got caught up in the momentum and they didn't see where it was hot headed
in until they hit the wall.
It sounds like you have a legitimate like chemical reaction to it.
It doesn't just sound like,
um,
it doesn't just sound like an abusive relationship because the effect that,
that it was having,
the extreme paranoia fact and the unease.
Do you take care of your body?
Do you work out?
Do you do any exercise
enough?
Not Enough.
I do some,
I do some calisthenics.
I don't,
I don't do a whole lot of,
you should do my yoga.
How do you not do yoga?
You should do yoga,
man.
Graham Hancock Yoga has your name on it.
Oddly enough,
somebodies come up to me recently and,
and suggested I join a yoga or yoga.
Listen man,
you have to join it yesterday.
Okay.
For Real.
It's for a guy like you because it's a way to get high without doing any,
any drugs I've gotten,
there's only one time in my whole life I did it,
but I got so high after a yoga session that it was like,
I just smoke weed.
Like I felt exactly like,
like I just smoked a lot of weed now was sitting there in a hotel room and I was
like,
this is incredible.
Like I would swear I'm high as fuck right now.
I hadn't smoked in dance.
Okay,
okay.
And it gives you,
um,
it's a reset and it gives you a reset.
It gives you like a to me,
like it gets rid of the excess in balances things out.
Like three.
You can,
the reason why people have road rage and the reacting so strongly to nothing.
What a guy got in front of you and it's going to take you three extra seconds to
get where you're going.
You go crazy and fucking dad is not him.
And that is not this the guy.
Yes,
maybe he shouldn't have done that.
But there's a degree bothering you.
Does it mean anything?
I got in front of you.
What's the big deal?
Yeah,
that's built up.
It's built up and there's imbalance.
It's energy and balances and people and yes,
we all,
we were stuck in cubicles or doing jobs that we don't appreciate and people blow
up.
And the best way to,
uh,
avoid that kind of stuff to me is yoga.
Yeah.
Well,
but what about all the,
the stretching and the,
you know,
the joy in my knees and my hips.
I have a high high,
my hip replaced six weeks ago.
Oh my God,
you did six weeks ago,
six weeks ago,
six weeks ago I was in hospital.
I got a massive scar down the outside of my right thigh.
They replaced my replay to replace my hip,
but I guess I wasn't,
could start gently and just sort of build up.
You would have to talk to an expert about that.
Cause I don't know what physical limitations,
the thought the surgery had gone well.
And uh,
I'm all set.
So they told you you were running.
I can go running,
I can go swimming.
I can do anything,
you know.
Wow.
That's incredible.
And it's like it's a serious operation.
Serious operation.
I know it's a serious operation because I helped it to stay awake during it.
Oh,
well I'm a writer,
you know,
I have to stuff to write about it.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Tell them that.
Yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
So what they do is they give you a spinal.
Um,
so it's an epidural.
It's a bit like an epidural that women get when they're giving,
giving birth.
It's slightly different,
but that's basically what it is.
And that freezes the lower half of your body.
You use the use of your legs,
you're paralyzed and there's no,
there's no pain whatsoever.
But then because they regard the operation as a,
the surgery is kind of scary procedure.
They then give you massive dose of sedatives and you kind of go off into
dreamland.
So I declined those.
Um,
and they wouldn't actually let me look.
They put some kind of curtain device between my face and my hip,
but I heard the soil.
Then I heard the hammering.
Oh Man.
I felt like he's fairly sure.
I had a carpenter's bench,
you know,
I heard them talking.
It was interesting.
It was an interesting experience,
but then very nice to come out of it,
be fully awake afterwards and gradually the feeling comes back to your legs.
And uh,
I spent four days in the hospital and initially I thought it was going to be
very tough and I thought it'd be on sticks for a long time.
But I did the physio and I just carried on working,
working,
edit and I'm okay.
I stayed awake for my first knee surgery.
Right.
And uh,
while the guy was working,
it was really weird because I was like half in it and half out of it.
And he was,
you know,
he was just a guy that was like tired of being a doctor.
I really wasn't into people or whatever it was.
I mean,
he fixed my knee,
it's still fixing his day,
a Patella tendon graft or they take a slice of your Patella and they open you up
and take a piece of bone out of your shin and a piece of bone in your kneecap.
And they used that to replace your interior cruciate ligament.
Right.
And um,
they,
he puts it in there and like moves my leg around.
He goes,
well,
better than it was.
That's what he says.
And he said like,
I was awake.
Right,
right.
Like I don't know if he just forgot it was awake or thought I wouldn't remember.
But I remember him moving around like,
well,
I don't know.
It was like,
like that's it not we,
we've got it done.
A beautiful job.
This young man will be up and walking and no time better than it was because
ambition,
who,
his attitude,
it was just like,
so he didn't give a fuck.
And I remember visiting him to get it looked at like after,
you know,
he would like want to do a checkup to see how it was like months later,
like the guy just didn't like people he could tell had the thing,
it's just done.
Just done.
There was no bedside manners.
Yeah.
He was courteous.
He wasn't yelling at you or anything,
but it was just,
you would just another piece of meat on the table.
Yeah.
It's,
it's weird to watch though,
isn't it?
Your body getting operated on
very strange experience to undergo.
And in my sense in my case has had,
was not able to watch it because they put up occurred,
but I heard it and the particular things that I heard were sewing
and hammering.
I saw it on a screen.
Right.
I didn't it,
I didn't watch it.
I couldn't watch it in front of me,
but I saw what was happening on screen.
It was crazy.
It was real weird though.
They will open you up like a fish and yeah.
But the hip replacement is a gigantic one.
That's a big,
it's a big surgery.
How was it six weeks later and you're walking around like you're great.
Well I just have a limp at all.
No,
I guess I,
I guess in some ways I've,
I've,
I must've been reasonably fit and um,
got on.
You know,
that's good.
Cut.
Cut Back.
That's a very important,
cause I know for folks that are like overweight or have these shoes already
allow like a hip injury to let them get overweight.
Yeah.
That's a big Rican,
you know,
rehabilitation.
It's a,
it's a big,
it's a big thing and it,
and it is major surgery,
the end of your bone off.
So,
so we made in a way,
our buddies are like machines and we've got this ball and socket joint and the
hip.
Um,
and so the ball is on the end of the long bone.
The femur I think it is.
And they,
so they chopped that off.
That comes off.
Okay.
And then the socket,
in my case,
they were cysts in the socket,
which hollow spaces that had come in there because of the,
the,
the ball joint was out of,
was out of kilter and it was rubbing in the wrong way.
And this is why it was called,
it was called,
I was in severe pain for a year before this happened.
And um,
and so they put in,
what they do is they put in a titanium unit there where the socket is and they
put it to Tanium shaft that goes,
that they hammered down into the bone.
But then,
but then on the top of the Tanium is ceramic.
So the actual bearings,
both the,
the,
the titanium socket is lined with ceramic and the bearing that moves around in
it and that sits on top of the detainees,
IOM shaft,
that's also ceramic.
So there's no metal rubbing against metal,
which has caused problems in the past.
People get fragments of metal into their bloodstream and so ceramic and ceramic
bearings,
um,
and uh,
and it's very good.
You know,
it works well and I'm not in pain and,
and,
and uh,
that very bad,
bad period of not being able to walk more than a quarter of a mile without
having to sit down and recover.
It's all gone.
It's incredible.
I mean,
how long is it going to be before we have bionic parties?
Well,
what's already happening?
We're already getting burning and,
and this is one of the good things,
which medical medical science had done some terrible things.
But one of the good things it's done is,
is,
I mean,
this is,
this had happened 50 years ago.
I would have been crippled at the age of 62.
I couldn't have gone on with my life.
Eventually did in Hunter Thompson.
Right.
Who was in constant pain?
Pain.
Yeah.
I believe he had hip replacement two,
but it was like old school.
They didn't really,
yeah,
they've got a lot better.
A lot better.
Yeah.
That's the image right there.
We're looking at it up on that screen.
There we go.
Yeah.
Oh God.
Graham Hancock.
Louisa's.
Ooh,
it's crazy.
It's the idea that you're going to run around on that.
That's a fake fake joint.
When you hammer that titanium shaft down inside the bone,
is there any danger that you could split the burn and he said,
yeah,
sure.
Sometimes split the boat,
but he said,
then we just turned,
we just find it
with wire card.
You just,
what you fucking tied up with duct tape is so crazy.
The Hammer,
a piece of metal into the s,
the center with a marrow is mother fucker.
Yeah.
Does it danger in danger?
The leg does it.
Wow.
That's incredible.
It's good.
It's good stuff.
And then the body just absorbs the titanium or it was part of the buddy bone
tissue forms around as well and,
and you're all set and mates to it,
right?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's incredible.
I'm pleasantly surprised by the way that this has has turned out.
I thought I like,
I'm here in America now.
I thought I would have to take sticks with me on this trip.
Wow.
I haven't had to do so.
You planned on taking sticks?
I did,
but in the end I decided not to.
It's incredible.
And you're just walking around totally normal.
I don't want to,
I have neat screws in both knees.
I don't know why I'm so surprised,
but I just,
I,
for whatever reason,
a hip replacement seems like an incredible,
yeah,
it's kind of intimate as well.
You know?
It's right in the center in being there.
It's kind of,
it's right next to junk.
That's what I'm saying.
I mean that sounds incredibly in the way it feels,
you know?
That's what it is.
There's a vulnerability.
It's it's inches away from your penis and they're sawing.
Plus,
I mean,
I said,
well,
since we did the business of revelations here,
they have to the,
the other thing that they have to
do when you go and you have the surgery for the 24 hours after the surgery is
you have to have a catheter
through the penis and into the plateau.
Because for those first 24 hours,
you cannot get up out of bed and you can't lift up to use a bed pans.
So they stick in a catheter.
And I felt,
I felt I wanted that out as soon as possible.
I wanted to out as soon as possible.
I wanted to return to autonomy over my body as quickly as possible.
I did not want it to be subject to the whims or fantasies of others I want.
And I made a big fuss about this.
I wanted the catheter out the next morning and they said,
and I literally,
it was up on a Zimmer frame than the by midday the next day and hobbling,
hobbling to the,
uh,
to the toilet.
So how many days was it before he could walk?
So I was walking the very next day on his fight on a Zimmer frame.
Yeah.
And they tell you to do this.
Yup.
You'll have to get going.
You can't sit there and do nothing.
You got to get going.
So I walked on a Zimmer frame,
then I walked on to two sticks and then I then one stick.
And how long to one's to,
oh,
I only got rid of the one stick about 10 days ago.
So it was a how long in before you could do one sec?
Um,
let's say a four and a half weeks.
Four and a half weeks.
You just walking around with a cane?
Yeah.
Wow.
Worth it.
I'm very happy.
I'm very happy that I had it done and that I don't have to suffer the pain cause
I had severe osteoarthritis.
I don't know why.
I mean,
we all think we're young,
you know,
I,
I feel,
I feel young.
I mean,
I'm 62 and,
and I,
I don't know why I was afflicted with this at,
at an age when most people who go for hip replacement,
they're into their seventies,
you know,
so I don't know why it hit me so hard.
I liked the line from leaders of the lost Ark.
You know,
where,
where Indiana Jones is all beat up sitting in the ships ships cabin and some
cabin.
And The lady with him comments on his appearance,
you know,
and he says,
it's not the years,
it's the mileage.
And I think I put down some mileage over the years.
Well,
I know a lot of martial artists,
they get hip replacements.
Mark Coleman,
former UFC heavyweight champion,
just a tweeted that he's going in for a hip replacement.
Even.
We're actually,
he's already done it.
And I believe Chuck Norris has had hip replacements.
It's very common.
Yeah.
And I have a,
a buddy,
my friend Shuki who's a Moitai instructor,
I believe he was in line for a hip replacement the last time I saw him.
It's,
um,
it's a weird joint sometimes,
which I,
but the good news is it's,
it's doable.
And after a few weeks of pain and discomfort to your back on your feet and fully
functional,
unless the surgeon screws up,
which they do sometimes I wonder about guys like,
um,
uh,
Bo Jackson,
he was a,
a football player that was injured really badly and he had to get a hip
replacement and it basically ended his career.
Uh,
he was playing football and baseball at the same time.
He was a super athlete,
like incredible athlete.
But if they could have fixed him with this back then,
it seems like he could have continued playing football.
That's insane.
Yeah.
Football and an artificial hip.
But why,
why should I be shocked?
You know?
I mean,
we have metal tubes that fly to other countries.
Why should I be shocked that they can fix your,
your hip?
Yeah.
Um,
and what that comes down to is they can wear your quality of life has
deteriorated because of pain and the mobility.
You can recapture that.
You don't get your quality of life back.
And that's what,
uh,
what I've already,
okay,
that's another place where cannabis is a beautiful drug.
When you're injured,
you know,
just give you a sense of ease of your body.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's for people that are in pain,
you know,
people have back problems.
This is a wonderful
things.
I have to say that I did wonder and I still do wonder,
um,
whether the fact that I quit cannabis in October,
2011 and started feeling severe hip pain just three months later in the early
part of 2012 whether there's some connection or whether the cannabis was either
in some way,
um,
protecting me from the onset of severe osteoarthritis or whether at least was
reducing
my sensitivity to the pain,
the osteoarthritis.
Cause that's when I started noticing it.
So your body was just out of alignment.
The hip was out of socket or something was wearing in a funny way,
it was wearing
funny way.
It seemed that,
that,
that ball socket joint was not,
was not quite the right shape and
I was just a natural,
some kind of some kind of natural thing.
When you talked about the Iowasca experience and you talked about the,
the,
the goddess coming to you and that you choose to believe that it's real.
Um,
my,
my thoughts on this whole what is real and what is not real thing,
what I've been thinking lately is that it doesn't really even matter because
what it is is it's about the experience itself and the,
the best parts of psychedelic experiences are the learning parts.
It sounds like so boring to people because they think like,
oh no,
I thought it was going to see amazing things and I was going to watch elephants
fly and it was going to be,
you know,
mad hallucinations,
which yeah,
it does occur sometimes,
but that's,
that's not what it's really about.
What it's really about is about a learning experience.
It's about massive leaps in development of your personality and your psyche,
your worldview,
your personal view,
and these,
these massive leaps that happened through psychedelics,
they happen exactly the same way.
If you really do in counter goddess or if this goddess is just conjured up by
your imagination in incredibly vivid detail,
either one is the same experience to you personally.
I think that's a very important point,
very important point because yes,
it might be hallucination,
but it is immensely beneficial or it might not be a hallucination and we might
not have a full account of what the fuck goes on in the human consciousness,
especially during altered states.
And to aid to go one way or the other I think is absurd to do that.
We don't need to,
we don't know.
Here is an incredible,
doubly
valuable experience.
Yes.
Uh,
which is,
which is available to us and which,
uh,
let's not forget that humanity has had a long relationship with these plants.
Uh,
this is,
this is one of the,
I think one of the problems again,
caused by the war on drugs,
which is that it sought to intervene in that relationship and demonize and,
and make it a dangerous to use them because you might get sent to prison.
You can't get sent to prison for a,
for a very long time.
People live in fear.
What we need is a,
is a nurturing society which makes it possible for people to have these
experiences in the safest,
most loving environment.
The love is love is key.
If you're feeling threatened in your head at a particular time,
if you're in a,
if you're in a space that that is,
is uncomfortable or difficult for you,
chances are the psychedelic experience.
We'll also be uncomfortable and difficult.
Um,
the more that you can control the space,
the,
that,
uh,
you can be surrounded by others who love you and have your best interests at
heart,
the more likely you are to have a very beneficial experience from that.
And though that those beneficial experiences can and frequently do include
painful moments when you come to realization of,
of actually who you are and what and what you are.
And,
and this is,
I mean it's absolutely fundamental with Iowasca is what I call the life review.
Um,
where you,
you see the impact of your behavior on others,
which previously you had insulated yourself from.
And when you see the pain you'd caused,
you might've felt perfectly justified at the time.
When you see it and you see it there with that clarity,
it makes you strongly motivated not to do that again.
So it's a very important learning experience.
They call them plant teachers,
they called them teachers in the Amazon.
That aspect that,
that learning from your past mistake aspects exist and a lot of psychedelics,
it's a core factor of,
so I'd say it's a core factor of,
of all psychedelic.
And I've always felt,
I always felt like,
it's really ironic that law enforcement works against psychedelics because
nothing would benefit law enforcement more than psychedelics.
Psychedelics were legal.
There'd be so many less crimes.
First of all,
the drug crimes be out the door and then it would be a matter of how many people
are on mushrooms going to rob your house.
How about zero?
You know,
it means they would ask you for food if they were that starving.
Yeah.
I just think that we have this incredible ally,
uh,
that our,
our culture,
our society,
we have this amazing plant thing that we've discovered in several different
forms.
Yeah.
And we've made all of them outside of our reach.
We put all of them outside legal reach,
which is insane.
It's insane.
It makes you wonder what's going on.
Why,
why,
why is society on this self destructive trip ignorant?
It's essentially with,
this is,
I believe,
and this is,
it sounds crazy,
but I believe this.
I believe that psychedelics are here for human beings to take,
to move to the next level of consciousness and they can elevate us away from our
war ways.
I'm with you on,
I think it's the only thing,
the only thing I don't think ideology,
morality shifts with understanding with the exchange of information.
I think morality,
escalate slowly but surely all throughout culture.
And eventually may,
we may get to a term or a time in the future where we're not war like at all.
But the best way to do that is through psychedelics.
Psychedelics and yeah,
the,
the people who are involved in the running of things most likely are ignorant to
the experience.
And so what you're dealing with is someone who is 50 60 years into a lifelong
close to off ego trip of death and destruction.
And they're the ones that are running the world,
unfortunately,
that that's,
that's why we're so fucked.
We're not so fucked because humans are evil.
And when you look around at all the nice people that you meet,
you get really confused as to how the world can be so fucked up.
Can it be so fucked up?
Because they build up basically.
Yeah,
we're good.
But the people that are running shit,
most of them are not good.
Yeah.
And,
and then they get like the personality types.
Like,
I mean,
if you want to run shit,
then right there you've got a certain kind of personality.
Yeah.
Anybody that wants to be president should not be allowed to be proud of exactly.
Instant this qualification,
you know,
you should be,
you'd be absolutely not wanting that job would be like the lottery.
You know,
like you should like the public,
like a new president comes in every month.
If you do a good job,
you know,
you get to keep the people get to vote whether we keep you for a few months.
Yeah.
And it's just a person.
You have a random qualifications as far as education,
as far as your background,
some power hungry EGOMANIAC who wants to push you around,
which is,
which is unfortunately the case,
the old boy network,
the thing that comes into place when these guys [inaudible] cronies and they all
help each other out and hook each other up and communicate with each other.
And then there's lobbyists and special interest groups and they all want to make
sure that this keeps going.
So that makes sure that the law has continued to stay on the books that allowed
them to deal with the stupidity,
especially when like Congress can't be guilty of insider trading.
Have you seen that?
I didn't see that.
Let me Google that because I want to make sure that I'm correct.
Congress not guilty of insider trading.
I think you can't accuse them of insider trading.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh dear.
Is the right way to say that?
Let me,
let me Google that to make sure that that's true.
Congress.
So basically they get immunity.
Yeah.
Uh,
hold on.
I wrote it the wrong can't be,
maybe can't be Lt.
Okay.
Immune to insider trading.
Hmm.
Let's try immune.
Yeah.
There's something,
I'm looking at some articles on this here.
Okay.
Well politicians are always cutting themselves.
All the slack there is,
you know,
that do,
that is exactly what it is.
Congress believes there are,
there are immune to insider trading laws and uh,
there's,
are there legal professors that are debating them.
Um,
and uh,
the legal analysis by law professor Donna Nagli of the Indiana University
suggest that members of Congress may not be immune to insider trading laws after
all.
Apparently there was a 60 minutes piece where they went on about this.
So it's one of those legal things where apparently this is probably,
you have to go over it with a fine tooth comb and then find out what,
what exactly the staff,
how it's written.
It's all crazy.
Bunch of corrupt Boston's you.
That's it.
They wanted to,
they wanted,
they wanted to do that job because they like controlling other people.
Fact that they can say that they don't want to be prosecuted for insider
trading.
It's like,
why is that?
How much are you doing?
How much inside?
Guess what?
You can come to me all day and you say,
Hey Joe,
do you think the insider trading should be illegal?
I'll say yes,
and if I do insider trading,
prosecute me.
But if I'm coming out saying,
I don't want you to prosecute me for insider trading,
definitely got something to hide to fucking dude,
man.
That's why you want it to be a congressman so you can just profit off of the
stock market.
You creep.
So I thought,
and I've made this proposal several,
several that,
um,
that what,
you know,
what I would like to see is anybody running for high office,
they first started right off.
They've got to do 10.
I was concessions.
It's a great idea.
You know,
that's it.
That's,
that's the first,
that's the first hurdle.
They've got to do that.
They've got to go through it and we'll see how they feel afterwards.
Um,
could be 10,
you know,
strong mushroom sessions.
So we're just as good.
But,
uh,
you know,
they've got it.
They've got to be able to do that.
You know what's really crazy?
The solution exists
to a better world.
It exists.
It exists right here.
It's not like we,
wow,
imagine if some benevolent race from another planet came down here and be gifted
us with some space fruit.
And if we eat this space fruit,
we'll see ourselves for who we truly are.
People hold,
they're letting go of their responsibility for their own lives,
you know?
Yes,
yes.
But if you told people that,
that you would go,
wow,
that would be great,
but it's science fiction.
Yeah.
Well,
the exact thing exists with Iowasca psychedelic mushrooms.
That's true.
It exists.
And for whatever reason,
you know,
discussing it is a very controversial thing.
It's very controversial.
Like I've,
I've like had producers like ask me like,
why are you talking about TV shows and I'm working on why are you talking about
illegal drugs
been asked.
I've been asked to stay away from those.
Yep.
Chorus don't talk.
You're going to fuck up this whole thing,
this ancient archeology.
I think you're on to something,
Graham.
I think you've done some good work.
Believe the mushrooms out putting exactly.
I've had that crash.
Had that conversation.
You don't need,
the mushrooms were making some money over here,
Graham.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's,
it exists.
And I think that was part of the problem with my ted talk to,
okay.
Yeah.
We could live in a Narnia world.
We could live in a world like Avatar.
If everybody was doing Iowasca,
we could pull this world together with a rapid quickness.
Yeah.
If they just broke out IOWASCA ceremonies all over the globe.
If it became the next big thing,
sort of like cell phones.
Everybody's got IOWASCA ceremony is on every corner.
We,
you could change the whole world within our lifetime in an astounding loving way
where people would abandoned so many of your ideas about business and so many of
their ideas about controlling resources and killing people.
And you know,
the amazing thing is that it is actually,
it is actually happening admittedly on a small scale,
but for me,
this is one of the mysteries of,
of Iowasca at a time when the Amazon jungle is under such terrible threat that
out of the jungle emerge these two plants,
one of which is a vine,
you know,
which then begins to spread her tentacles or all around the planet and to call
out to people.
And people are drawn to Iosco.
I can't tell you how often I get asked a,
where do I go for,
for a good Iowasca ceremony where I know I can trust the sham on it to get it
again,
as it's happening everywhere,
it's happening in Japan,
it's happening in,
it's happening in Germany,
it's happening,
it's happening all over the world.
And so you get a,
uh,
a small but growing group of,
of,
of initiates who have had this shared experience.
And uh,
you know,
we kind of know each other when we meet
and the initiates that have had this experience are talking about it and more
are coming.
It's building and building and the Io Oscar tourism and south Americans gigantic
now.
So it's really,
yeah.
And I again,
a number of times I stabbed up at the,
and I'm giving a,
a presentation somewhere and I'm talking about Iowasca and then somebody stands
up in the audience.
They don't,
you realize that by promoting Iowasca you're leading to the depletion of the
rain forest.
Quite the opposite is the truth is the case.
Uh,
the,
what's happened with Iowasca is the Iowaska is being massively planted in the
rainforest now because of Iowasca tourism.
Iowasca tourism is a really good thing for,
I'll ask it.
It's not causing any depletion.
And,
and uh,
I'll ask,
it can be grown in many different parts of the world.
And it is,
and it has been being grown.
That's the divine.
So
it's a,
it's,
it's a really,
it's a fascinating subject.
The fact that something does exist to give you that experience.
Yeah.
I've always said about the,
the DMT experience at like,
if you could just show someone like what you see if you,
without taking it,
if you could just show someone,
yeah.
They would want to do it.
They would want to go wait a minute and it doesn't hurt.
You know,
it doesn't,
you're not going to get hurt.
But most people,
most people probably shouldn't do it though.
That's what I think.
Also what I think,
and I think even baby steps.
Yeah.
If we lived in that ideal world where we as adults have the right to make
sovereign decisions about our own consciousness,
I think most people wouldn't choose to do it.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
Well,
if you look at how it is in Holland where marijuana is essentially legal and
nobody,
you know,
like they look down upon people that get high all the time and they also look
down upon hard drugs because of the fact that you can get most things they
understand with great clarity.
What's dangerous and what's not dangerous and people are always going to make
bad money.
That's it.
You know,
you just have to treat people as adults and you have to understand that some
people will make mistakes and there will be problems,
but that is that that should not be an obstacle to what,
what has to be a fundamental freedom.
But what about allowing people into your community that sell them,
allowing people in your community of friends and neighbors that profit off of
the addiction of others because there are certain drugs like math.
I'm not saying that math should be illegal.
I don't,
I don't know whether or not you,
I don't know whether or not there's a way to handle it where you get the maximum
benefit.
I don't know whether it's making it illegal,
decriminalizing it,
making it so that people can't get prosecuted for using,
but they can get prosecuted for selling complicated area.
Some of these,
some of these substances are very harmful.
Personally,
I don't want to smoke meth,
but if you were next door to a math guy,
like you would not want that guy in your communities profiting off of,
in slaving chemical enslaving people.
So this is,
this is an area where more work has to be done.
But I think that,
I think if we approach the problem from a spirit of love
and from a spirit of respect for the sovereignty of other adults,
it'll be whole lot better than the way we are approaching the problem right now.
And as we know,
making these toxic substances illegal doesn't prevent their use.
It does,
it absolutely does not prevent,
they use,
the use has gone up and up and up and up and up,
over,
over the deck.
And it's kind of unique.
The,
the one of the properties of psychedelics,
whether it's,
uh,
like some per,
some works,
some forks,
um,
Ibogaine has a great result for curing addictions in Iowasca has a great result.
And the people that are doing these very things in selling these very drugs,
both participating in both sides,
selling and dealing could both benefit from my Oscar.
Like,
if you're,
if you're a meth dealer,
you're an asshole.
Like what an asshole.
You're,
you're selling something that fucking kills piano.
It makes them polar skin off of their face.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
One of the first,
um,
Iowasca sessions I went to in Brazil,
there was a guy there from la who,
who was a heavy smoker of crystal meth.
Oh,
Jesus.
And He,
um,
came there in a state.
He was just so wired and he came out as we were discussing,
as were talking,
it came out that he had been,
he had a rival in love and he'd gone out and got a gun and he,
and just before he left La,
but best decision he ever made was to leave La and come down to Brazil and drink
IOWASCA.
He was getting close to the point of murdering a fellow human being.
Um,
two weeks in Brazil,
five ios sessions,
completely turned him around,
completely turned them around and,
and he revolutionized his life and he became such a loving,
positive,
warm,
spirited person.
And all his anger was gone.
And,
and he moved on in his life in amazing ways.
And I've seen many,
many,
many examples of that.
I don't want to pretend,
however,
that it's all sweetness and light in the garden.
Um,
there,
there are problems also with,
with Iowasca and people should be aware of this.
There are Shamans who are abusing their power.
Uh,
there are,
uh,
you know,
if you've got to a place like a ketose in Peru,
you'll find those two types of showman's,
one type I the cure and Darrow's there,
the healers,
the other type of the brew hose there.
So sorceress actually and um,
they will use Iowasca to gain power over others.
And there have been one or two horrendous cases that occurred with this.
So I do think the,
the intention of the individuals who are involved is also an important part of
this.
And psychedelics,
I agree with you.
The,
the,
the single one stop shop to transform our society and make it a better place,
a far better place than it can be today is the correct use of psychedelics.
But I would be wrong to say that psychedelics are a magic potion because they're
not,
and there have been,
which have misused psychedelics profoundly.
I would say that the Aztecs in Mexico,
we're one of those.
What did they do?
Well,
they used Psilocybin,
but they did not use it for a gentle consciousness exploration.
The Aztecs used psilocybin preparatory to rituals of human sacrifice.
The Aztecs,
uh,
the Aztecs used psilocybin as a vehicle to communicate with their day teas.
And those deities included characters like we'd sort of partially who was the
war God who spoke to Marty Zuma was the last Aztec emperor and a,
that's 15,
19.
Uh,
when Cortez appears in Mexico.
And what is Zuma was in daily communication with,
with the war God,
by means of Psilocybin mushrooms and,
and what the war God was telling him to do.
You know,
there's demons out there as well as angels.
What the war God was telling him to do was to kill people and to stretch them
over a stone and cut out their hearts and their where there was a horrendous
situation in Tennessee state land,
which was the capital city,
which is now Mexico City.
As a matter of fact,
when they inaugurated the great pyramid,
reliable accounts,
80,000 people were sacrificed to the god of war and four days in four days,
80,000 people.
Now this is a,
this is a bloody awful thing that was going on there and psychedelics were in
Boston.
I'm not saying that psychedelics caused it,
and again,
we come to this issue,
is it,
are these entities that we encounter projections of our own minds or are there,
is there some other level,
more realm or level of existence where nonphysical entities that communicate
with us at the level of consciousness exist?
Uh,
whichever it is,
whether it's a projection of our own minds,
as you rightly say,
or whether those entities are real is less important than the effects on our
behavior.
But if what is being projected from our own mind is very dark and negative and
wicked,
or if those entities also include evil angels as well as good guys,
then you can get cultures misled down this path.
And I do believe that's what happened with the,
with the Aztecs.
There's also recently,
and again,
I think truth is really important.
Truth is really important.
So let's be truthful about this.
Also,
there have been some tragic cases with the,
with Iowasca most recently in Chile,
uh,
which,
which actually involved the human sacrifice,
which actually involved the,
the,
the burning to death of a,
of a baby on the instructions of the so-called Gulu or Sharman who formed the
kind of death cult,
but their sacrament was Iowasca.
Um,
this is very rare,
but it does happen and I think people should be aware when they enter Iowasca
space that one of the things I was good does is it makes you more suggestible.
It opens your heart,
it makes you,
it makes,
if,
if a powerful,
strong negative personality comes along and says to you,
do this,
do this.
You might just do it.
And that's,
that is also their possible.
So you have to,
you have to be strong in yourself.
You have to be clear on your intent.
And,
and,
and if you're not going into this with good intent,
then bad things also can happen.
Well,
I,
I just also wonder what would it be like to introduce psychedelics into the
insane warlike environment of Aztec Mexico and the 15 hundreds?
I mean,
what,
what would it have been like this living back then and what,
what would it take to become a PR person of royalty,
an emperor or king in those days?
It was insane.
Bloodshed.
It's just insane.
Theirs,
they were very dark and demonic culture.
And unfortunately,
that demonic aspect of avast tech culture was without any shadow of a doubt
mediated by psilocybin mushrooms.
And they called them [inaudible],
which means the flesh of the gods.
And they were used for communication with demonic entities.
And,
um,
we cannot,
we cannot pretend that that was not,
so this was the case.
And indeed,
if,
if the Aztecs had not been those people who murdered their neighbors,
who use their neighbors as a sort of farm.
I mean,
if you imagine a society which was run by serial killers and in the interest of
serial killers,
that's roughly as tech society and 1519 so they would have neighboring tribes
who they would pray on.
They could easily have completely defeated them,
but they preferred not to completely defeat them.
They preferred to use them for warfare every year,
make war on them,
take captives,
bring the captors back to Tennessee tech lab and cut out their hearts.
And this is why there's Karma.
There's such a thing as Karma.
Well,
this is why Montezuma was brought down,
I mean,
490 Spaniards turn up on the coast of Mexico and destroy a standing army of
200,000 men.
Why does that happen?
It happened because the neighbors of the Aztecs hated the Aztecs.
They utterly hated them.
And,
and they were looking for liberation from that,
from that horror that was being in.
Isn't that a better,
isn't that?
No,
I shouldn't say better,
but isn't a possibility that what you're dealing with is a bunch of sociopaths
and a bunch of crazy people.
And if you introduce psilocybin into their system in this insane warlike world,
that where you're conjuring up is their imagination.
And it is the,
the,
the inner,
I mean,
the desire to manifest these things that we ask them to do horrible things.
And this is a core behavior pattern in human beings when they get in control of
armies.
Yeah.
It is absolute complete total ruthlessness as barbaric behavior is,
not only is it,
is it beneficial,
but it's necessary.
It's applauded.
Yeah.
It's necessary.
When does your metals,
and if you don't do it,
someone around you is going to do it.
So you have to do it.
Yeah.
So there's the,
there's the interesting question right there.
I mean,
we have armies now in the world today,
which are going out doing murderous stuff.
Right.
Um,
and so the question is if we,
if we were to be in such a position that we could massively introduced
psychedelics into those,
into those armies,
would it actually make them worse or better?
This is,
I'm not sure what the answer is.
You know,
I'm not,
I'm not sure what the very honest of you to not be sure that is the,
I think there's no way that we,
sure.
We know that the,
the Vikings Ma,
they berserker on mushrooms,
they will use it.
How many of them are scary?
So scary?
I,
yeah.
Yeah.
I never had much luck with that.
Me Neither.
Yeah.
That's what I hear from a lot of people felt weird.
You want to have luck with it.
You've got to pass it through urine,
urine,
even pass it through a reindeer or through or through the bladder of a showman,
vandal WIC.
You know how convenient you have to drink.
Sharman pissed.
Yeah.
That's the thing that they always say you have to recycle your urine.
I'm like,
this is though the middle of the body functions as a filter and it removes set
and impurities,
which then allow the good stuff to remain.
And that comes through in your,
and apparently you can pass it through seven human bodies that doesn't lose.
Hey,
easy.
Um,
I know a,
a buddy who did it and he uh,
he was on mushrooms and they told him to drink his urine.
He's like,
I am so high right now.
I did not need to drink my urine.
And they're like,
trust me,
drink your urine.
And he said he drank his urine.
It was like just getting shot through a cyclone.
Boom.
He said the whole thing just took some incredible path.
Yeah.
From drinking his own urine.
I must say that's not an experience I've had.
What would welcome that.
But that's what the research shows.
I have drunk my own urine on several occasion.
Yeah.
Just to see,
cause I,
I read about year in therapy so I wanted to find out what it was about.
Like does it,
yeah.
Does it really make you feel better when you're sick and it did work.
But it might've been totally,
might've been placebo.
I Dunno.
But there was one time when I was sick and I took it.
I called my friend Yana,
but I'm like,
dude,
I track my own piss off work.
It was just,
it was crazy cause he was like big on it,
you know,
cause you're in therapy and we'll taste,
it doesn't taste nearly as bad as you would think it tastes.
The idea is a lot worse than the actual reality of it is hard to cross.
But it's just like warm water.
It's not horrific tasting gag a little when you smell it,
you know like you can't believe when I drank this.
But once you're actually drinking it,
it's really,
it's not that big a deal.
I'm haven't done in a long time.
I don't want to say like the Leo Machida who's a famous UFC fighter,
he drinks his own urine every morning and there's another guy,
Juan Manwell,
mark as a famous boxer from Mexico.
Same thing.
He was drinking his own,
I think he quit.
He gave up and you guys might as well have some laminated NASCAR.
Yeah.
And then,
yeah,
you might as well.
And even then,
yeah,
I wonder if when you're,
when a person goes completely psycho,
when you're living in war.
And one of the things about the Mexicans,
the Aztecs rather as a,
I don't even think they had horses yet.
No,
they didn't.
This is,
this is one of the reasons again why a relatively small force of Spaniards were
able to defeat them was because the horse
had been extinct in the Americas for 12,000 years.
Wow.
From the end of the last ice age.
And so when the Spanish turned up with actually only 16 horses,
16 heavy,
heavy hunters that were trained for,
for warfare,
uh,
European armies that had thousands of years to develop strategies to deal with
men on horseback and they were dead.
They were definite specific tactics and responses that you used when you were
charged.
But the,
the Maya and the Aztecs,
they had no idea what they were looking at there.
They actually,
if you look at their accounts,
which I've,
which I've done,
you'll find that they initially thought that they were dealing with supernatural
beings,
which we're part,
part deer actually.
Cause that was the nearest animal that they could relate to a horse park,
deer and part human.
Um,
and,
and they did a know how to handle these things and they,
you know,
they're coming down at you at 25 or 30 miles an hour.
They're covered in armor,
uh,
the horse and the man.
And,
and it's a pretty terrifying prospect.
And they broke armies of tens of thousands of men where we'd just fled in terror
at the,
at the site of these,
uh,
these entities charging down on them.
Eventually they learned.
Um,
and there's a famous case that one of the tribes in Mexico that fought most
vigorously against Montezuma,
where people called the class Collins.
He used them for human sacrifice and they're very independent spirited people,
great warriors.
And you would've thought when the Spanish came into Mexico,
that the first people who would become their allies would be the plus gallons.
But in fact,
that plus gallons had a heroic character called Chica Tanka who was their battle
king.
And he saw the future and he saw what,
what Spain would eventually due to Mexico.
And so initially and very hard,
he fought the Spanish tooth and nail for over a long campaign that lasted about
six weeks.
Um,
and during that,
during that campaign on one,
on one occasion,
one of his warriors actually took the head off a horse with a single blow of
their weapon,
which was a bit like a sword.
It was made of wood.
It was called a macro wheedle.
And it had flakes of obsidian lined along the edges of the blade.
And that horse was not wearing armor that day.
And the horse was beheaded,
shocked the Spanish.
It was the first time.
Suddenly there was proof for the people in front of them that these animals were
not supernatural,
that they could be,
that they could be killed.
And uh,
but eventually,
you know,
Cortez was a terrorist.
He went around massacring called villages.
He burned people at the stake.
He Fed people to dogs.
And eventually the coolest Carlin's did the calculation and they said,
we better join this guy rather than carry on with this.
And so eventually they did join forces with him and suddenly he had 100,000
auxiliaries who were ready to take a Moctezuma on Jesus Christ.
Who's cute.
Imagine living back then extraordinary times,
and I have to say,
although I,
although I really detest a lot of the things that the Spanish did,
I have to say those 490 they had balls
of steel.
You know,
they had balls of steel.
I mean to turn,
to turn up on this distant coast with no resources,
no reserves,
nothing to fall back on.
And to know that you're confronting a,
an enemy that is a militaristic power that has hundreds of thousands of men
under arms that sacrifices you if it catches you and still to go for it.
That takes tremendous coach Cortez actually scuttled all his ships so that his
men could not flee.
The ships were scuttled.
What does that mean?
It's cuddled sunk.
He sunk them.
Put holes in them.
Yeah,
we put holes in them and sunk them.
And gangster.
And,
and,
and then he said this is it.
There's no going back.
Jesus Christ,
we conquer,
we conquer or we or we die.
Fucking psycho.
Yeah.
So total psycho.
So it's been interesting for me cause this is my latest writing effort,
has been,
has been a novel about the Spanish conquest of Mexico these days.
I do novels as well as nonfiction.
It's been interesting for me to get inside the head of a man like Cortez to get
inside the head of a man like Moctezuma.
Uh,
and to add,
to figure out what,
what drove them and what,
what made these,
these characters,
what,
what they,
what they were.
And I have a witch in the story,
a young Aztec,
which,
and I have a famous woman called Molenaar who became Cortez Lover,
um,
who had a grudge against Montezuma history.
Doesn't tell us why,
but I give her a motive in the story cause he tried to sacrifice.
It's kind of cool that you can do that with history,
can do that with history and you can't,
you can do that with fiction.
And so she,
she's a key player in the,
in not just in my story,
but in the story of history because she became Cortez interpreter.
She was very clever.
She learned Spanish very,
very fast and she would be so in the paintings from those days,
you always see her standing beside Cortez and coming out of her mouth is the
glyphs that means speech.
And,
and she gave the whole story away to Cortez.
She told Cortez how to defeat Montezuma.
And that was to play on the myth of [inaudible] collateral of the feathered
serpent who would return and bring in a new age and overthrow a wicked king.
And she had Cortez fill the boots of quite sarco apple.
Wow.
How did you get so involved in the Aztec culture?
Just,
it's so fast.
This is the book by the way.
Oh God.
Yeah.
This is it.
Um,
when I was researching fingerprints of the gods back in the early nineties,
um,
I traveled extensively and widely in Mexico as part of my research because
Mexico is a fascinating place from the,
from the point of view of a lost civilization.
You know,
we have the old mech culture we have for these that those gigantic stone heads,
um,
from a site that's thought to be three and a half thousand years old.
I think it's probably much older than that on the Gulf of Mexico heads in the
form of African heads,
which is very puzzling and weird.
Um,
but also,
uh,
images of,
of people with very strongly Caucasian features with,
with massive beards.
Um,
definitely not American Indian faces.
And there they are.
So I was wondering,
are these the remnants of some lost civilization because history does not
explain how individuals with that appearance ever turned up in a,
in Mexico.
And I inadvertently,
as I was researching fingerprints of the Gods in Mexico,
I inadvertently traveled the route of Cortez and I found myself again and again
crossing the path that Cortez had taken from the Gulf of Mexico up to what is
now Mexico City.
And I began to realize there was a fascinating story to tell here and a story
that had never been properly told.
And I used the accounts of some of the cookies to doors.
Men like Ben Ideas who give us,
who give us eye witness,
accounts of Aztec society.
Uh,
this helped me to under because the Aztecs were late comers in the civilization
of Mexico,
but they only existed as a,
as a,
as an an empire for 200 years before Cortez came.
But they revered earlier cultures.
Um,
and,
and the particularly the,
uh,
amazing pyramid site of Teotihuacan 30 miles north of Mexico City was the,
which means the place where men became gods.
So I was investigating the possibility of a lost civilization,
but I was kind of imbibing the story of Cortez and,
and of the Aztecs at the same time.
And I felt this kind of Paul of sadness that hangs over and Mexico,
this feeling that something terrible happened there.
And what's at the heart of my story without,
without giving too much of it away,
is this,
is this notion of demonic influence that Montezuma and I accepted.
It could be projection of the individual's mind because he's just a particularly
wicked,
evil individual.
Or it could be that there are real demons out there.
So Montezuma is communicated with and advised by Witsell or possibly the war God
and Cortez is well known,
had believed he had a special relationship with Saint Peter.
Uh,
and that,
and he in dreams encountered Saint Peter and Saint Peter advised him to carry
out some of the most horrific acts of genocide that have been ever recorded in
the history of the Americas.
And so convenient.
There's,
yeah,
the speculation of the novel is that both the entity that appeared to Montezuma
as the war God and the entity that appeared to Cortez as Saint Peter,
we're actually one and the same demonic entity seeking to multiply human misery.
Cause that's what demons do.
And if we think it was bad under the Aztecs,
let's be honest and accept that it was a thousand times worse after the Spanish
took over the population of Mexico.
It was calculated to be 30 million in 15,
19.
Within 40 years it was 1 million.
29 million people died,
gigantic.
Wow.
Renders genocide and the Spanish were monsters.
This,
they would use people to test the edge,
their weapons.
Let's just see if we can chop off somebody's arm here.
Let's see what this acts will do.
Oh,
the dogs are hungry.
Let's just throw a bunch of people to the dogs.
That's where the phrase throwing them to the dogs comes from as a matter of
fact.
So they weren't,
they were awful people and it's been a dark story to write.
But I've,
I,
I've,
I've also found that in this,
in this world,
in this realm,
at that time there was,
there was the capacity for love,
the word decent people who did their best.
My Dad has a pretty sensible guy.
He's never for weirdness or spiritual shit.
He's just not that kind of guy.
But he was telling me about going to Gettysburg and he said that was a
horrendous battle.
And he said he could feel sadness in the air.
And he said it was in escapable.
It was almost overwhelming.
And he said,
I just didn't expect that.
He said,
you know,
I didn't,
I mean,
I don't know what it is.
I Dunno what it is.
Maybe it's the knowledge of what happened there.
He goes,
but I don't think so.
It's just like he goes,
it was like,
it was in the air penetrates the atmosphere.
And you felt that I felt that very strongly that there was this terrible sadness
hanging over myself.
I was always high.
It could have been that,
right?
Yeah.
Can we a high in Mexico?
You fucking gangster.
Damn.
That's dangerous.
Um,
I wanted to ask you about this because there's a guy in my message board,
his name is Frodo Swagmans,
and he sent me a cool link,
um,
to,
this new thing that's been found under tio two a con they found a jade mask from
an earlier era and um,
some,
some building,
some work underneath there that they're investigating now that they believe was
all men.
Yeah.
It doesn't surprise me at all,
I think.
I think we're gonna find the [inaudible] what con actually goes way back,
not just to the beginnings of the historical epoch,
but far deep into prehistory and all make these so called all Max of Central
America may go back 10,
12,000 years.
They may not be,
I don't think we should just limit them to the last three and a half thousand
years.
So this is the case with many of these sites.
It's the same,
by the way,
if you've got a church,
Anita,
if you can get inside the pyramid of cook,
can a chicken,
chicken,
Nissan,
Cook County is just another name for quite so quietal you'll find that it's
built on top of another pyramid,
which is inside it and older pyramid and preserved completely inside a new can
even get inside that that older pyramid,
and I think it's the case all over the world,
that sites have been built on top of all sites reincarnated in a way.
So there was an ancient sacred place and later cultures came along and honored
it and built new monuments on top of it.
But,
but the,
the mistake they are killed just make is that the origins of the site of the
later culture and they don't take account of the earlier culture.
Well,
that was one of the things that John Anthony West was suggesting about Egypt.
When we show that very different construction methods that coincidentally are
below the ground,
like you have to dig out the sand to pull these things up and oh,
Lo and behold,
they looked different.
Yeah.
And that's like the Syria
at um,
uh,
in Abby dose in Upper Egypt,
which is 50 or 60 feet lower than the temple of,
to first,
and was actually
covered with 50 feet of sedimentation until archeologists dug out.
But they still insist on giving it to seti the first.
Yes.
No,
it's a fascinating thing.
The denialism that's involved in Egypt,
Thailand.
It is Zoe.
Hawaiians dude is a trip just to watch him talk about them.
So like how were you in control of how this thing gets labeled or discovered or
researched and extraordinary things are his rise to power.
And then his subsequent fall,
is he in trouble now?
He's in deep shit.
Is he going to jail?
Yeah.
Corruption.
Um,
so,
well,
no,
he's made,
his main thing was that he was closely associated with the Mubarak family,
particularly with Susan Mubarak.
The wife of the deposed President Hosni Mubarak and they protected him so he
could do whatever he liked while Mubarak was running Egypt and therefore he was
one of the closest to Mubarak in the Egyptian regime.
So when Mubarak fell and a whole new system came into play in Egypt,
does that,
he was one of the first to go.
Uh,
it was a shocking the,
the,
the John Anthony West series magical Egypt is one of my favorites.
DVD series.
John is such a brilliant human being and he's devoted his life to exploring the
mystery of Egypt and the magic of Egypt.
This is,
this is what archeologist never do.
And if he's listening,
I owe you an email,
dude.
I swear to God,
I'm gonna email you back quick.
I'm just been crazy busy cause even like stairs with John Today,
I've been so swamped with this new TV show that I'm doing that I,
I'm,
I'm behind on everything.
Text messages and emails and all that.
But I'm a big fan of that guy's work and that magical Egypt things.
Just one of the most stunning documentary series I've ever watched.
It's it,
it's like 10 DVDs or something like that.
It's amount of work.
Corporate incorporating.
Yeah.
John's just vast encyclopedic knowledge of the mysteries of Egypt.
It's all,
it's all,
it's all expressed in there.
Incredible.
So John is about to be vindicated,
I would say.
Um,
he and Robert Schoch from Boston University,
we did,
this was John's work initially and Robert Schoch became involved in it,
which was the,
you'll remember the argument about the Sphinx and the Sphinx.
There's very characteristic erosion marks both on its body and on the trench dug
around it.
And that those are the marks of precipitation induced weathering of exposure to
thousands of years of heavy rainfall.
Cut a long story short,
no such rain fall in Egypt in the last 5,000 years.
You have to go back 10,
12,000 years,
the end of the last ice age to get that kind of climate.
And then you have to have thousands of years of those conditions to create that
together.
Get that,
to get that weathering.
So when John and John Anthony West and Robert Schoch and dropped this bombshell
on Egyptology in roughly 1992 that the Sphinx actually might be thousands of
years older than the Egypt Egyptologists imagine there was a huge outcry and
egyptologist became very,
very angry about it because they were threatened and the in the core of their
being.
And one of the arguments they made,
which they thought was the killer argument was,
look,
you're this monument is 12,000 years old,
but there are no other large monuments anywhere in the world,
which are 12,000 years old.
Unfortunately for the Egyptologists,
that's no longer true because there's the,
just the most amazing site has been discovered in Turkey called go back Beckley
Cathy.
Yeah,
we talked about the last time you had amazing and,
and it was deliberately buried by the people who've made it 14,000 years.
Well,
no,
they,
it looks like it was made 12,000 years,
12 to deliberately buried 10,000 years ago.
And that means that no later culture has trumped over it to confuse the dating
record.
And therefore we have a pristine site.
And when a site is pristine and it's approached by a mainstream archaeologists
such as clash spirit from the German archeological institute who's the
excavator,
he has to honestly put his hand on his heart and say,
this side is 12,000 years old.
And if got Beckley Tempe as 12,000 years old,
then there's no reason on earth why this thinks shouldn't be 12,000 years old.
And if the Sphinx and go back to the Tempe at 12,000 years old,
and I'm sorry we have to rewrite the history book.
There was a real weird moment,
um,
on whatever documentary it was that showed a Robert Schoch presenting his
findings because he's an academic and he's the only one that they would allow to
present.
And that sort of geology at Boston University.
And John Anthony West is not an academic and he's an Egypt expert.
He's a guy who's immersed himself in Egypt his whole life.
But I don't know what his formal education is,
but the fact that that guy hasn't given,
been given some sort of uh,
at least like someone test him and give the guy a fucking degree because like
who the hell knows more about ancient Egypt and John Anthony West and it should
obviously his credentials should be examined and I'm in his,
his,
his word should be checked but I'm sure that he's on,
I mean he's on,
I've never heard a single thing about any of his translations about any of his
disc that it seemed to me anything less than country,
if there were negative,
like it didn't make any sense at all.
Like I think he's a pretty astounding person when it comes to knowledge
person and I beat the case.
I think that he's brought a unique insight to ancient Egypt and he's done far
more for the exploration of the past than any credentialed Egyptologists.
Yeah.
So now that go,
Beckley tap has been clearly established at least 10,000 years old.
That's when it was cause the best stuff is the oldest 10,000 years,
10,000 years ago,
like a time capsule.
They bury it and by the way,
it's only 5% of it has been excavated.
A huge vast area be who knows what the hell they're going to find under there,
whether they're going to find artifacts or what have you.
That that explain things a little bit better but we know people were capable of
doing that thing.
Now that's 100%
and therefore if they're capable cause some of those megaliths way up,
one of them weighs 50 tons.
You know,
go back to the Tempe is a stone circle.
There's a circle of a series of stories of stone circles and therefore we're
looking at a culture that 12,000 years ago was already capable of doing that.
In other words,
we can't say that they just made that up overnight.
Right.
There has to be a long background to that.
That got them to the point where they could do that and that that is why go back
to Tapi is the single most important archeological site in the world because it
could not have appeared by magic.
It had to be the result of a culture which had figured out how to work with
large and heavy blocks of stone and to add to query them and carve them and move
them around and that we're not our ancestors.
I supposed to have been a hunter gatherers,
you know,
living in small groups,
um,
without any large scale organization and go back to the top.
It gives the light of that
and there's a very sophisticated carving method employed on these,
these beams,
a three dimensional carving method where instead of carving the image into the
stone itself,
which is the easy way to draw something,
they actually left the piece of stone.
Yeah.
Like if they drew a lizard,
it would cut away everything else and leave the lizard to stand out.
Exactly.
That's very difficult.
High relief.
It's extremely,
it's extremely difficult to do.
And again,
it takes practice.
It takes a culture that's worked on that.
So we have to say there's a background to this,
which goes thousands of years earlier than the site that we found and as more
excavation is done,
I believe more and more of that is,
is going to come out.
So
one of my favorite quotes of yours is that we're a civilization with Amnesia
spaces with amnesiac needs.
Yeah.
It's,
it's such a great way of putting it because when you keep digging holes and
finding things that are like old as fuck,
like go back to the temp was found by a farmer,
right.
And it was just putzing around and was like,
what the hell is this?
He kicks it,
he moves it around.
It's like this is weird.
He starts digging and boom.
It's one of the most important archeological findings ever.
Absolutely.
But none of this existed while you guys were dealing with Zalia hos no,
no.
I was watching that.
And the other thing was the other academic who he was communicating with,
whatever that guy's name is,
no need to even say it in such a country.
You human being
the way he was laughing,
like what culture are we talking about?
But he existed 10,000 years.
That just,
why,
why is that funny to you?
That's him remain nameless.
I know who you remember the name was and um,
yeah,
they pour scorn on these,
on these ideas.
Intellectual score.
No,
fucking arrogant.
You know,
not all of them.
No,
not all of them,
but I mean most of them are doing amazing things.
The reason why you have an incredible hip,
I cry some bad mother fuckers in academia.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm not insulting science as such as humans.
Just shitty ego is just some Shitty,
ego-driven human.
Yeah.
Is,
and it happens that archaeology is one of those areas of study which is very
territorial and where,
where scholars have staked their reputation on a particular view of the past and
they get very angry when anybody threatened threatens that.
And they're very,
very,
very obnoxious to one another as well as to outside.
And they've told this story and given degrees based on what they've taught for
decades.
Yes.
Decades after,
decades after decades.
And to all of a sudden step in and say,
we were wrong.
Yeah,
there's no way this guy,
you know,
it's very difficult to do.
It's very,
very to do.
And,
and in saying these negative things about Egyptology,
I also do want to say that they also do great work.
There's a fantastic work has been done by Egyptology.
Um,
and,
and I don't think that I could have written any of my books if I hadn't been
able to draw on the,
on the huge amount of data that,
that Egyptology has provided.
But sometimes I put a different interpretation on it from the one that they put
on it.
So I don't want to put them down completely.
They've done,
they've done great work,
but they're narrowly focused on a particular reference frame,
a particular idea of how human history evolved.
And they should let the evidence speak for itself rather than impose that.
And we should point out that on it.
We should point out that there is a small group of people,
um,
that,
uh,
not a small group.
I shouldn't even say I shouldn't quantify them.
Um,
there's some people believe that the water erosion,
the feature,
it was actually wind and sand.
Um,
I've,
I've seen that argument and um,
I'm not a geologist obviously,
but when I saw Robert Schoch deal with that argument,
it doesn't seem to hold,
shucks.
Got An excellent answer tool to all of that and add it is not,
it is not we'd weathering so it was not sand.
Anyway,
the Sphinx was covered with sand for a very long
comes like cuts down and in it looks like water had been pouring down for a long
time.
Cutting grooves into the Roth in groovy.
Like,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know though.
I'm not,
I'm not qualified to,
that's why.
Why shock,
you know,
it has made a marvelous contribution to this whole field because he is a credit
shield academic.
He is a geologist and he's been prepared to put his reputation on the line and
say,
I'm sorry.
I think the sinks is really,
really helpful.
Yeah.
What bothers me about the people that debunk it is they claim to be correct.
The people that look at it,
it's very obvious you're dealing with some pretty significant erosion.
So why is it so different looking than the erosion on the outside of the Sphinx,
which looks like when sand.
Yeah.
Why are you dealing with it in this enclosure where this thing was buried for so
long?
Like why?
Why is it different here?
Is it the type of stone?
Is that what it is?
I mean,
what is it or is it evidence of an older time?
Is it possibly something that was built into some malleable stone a long fucking
time ago and then pretending that it's not possible?
It's kind of silly.
It's kind of silly because you don't know.
We don't have it really accurate map of what happened 10,000 years ago.
How do you know that the history of science as such,
we know again and again
that fixed and rigid views about how the world is do get overthrown.
It didn't get changed,
but reluctantly in summary with a fight,
but eventually the new evidence overwhelms the old and I think we're in the
realm of ancient history.
We are poised on the verge of that kind of revolution.
I think it's got to happen
with Zoe Huw os out of the picture.
Is it possible now that can excavate some sites that they weren't allowed to
before?
Like I know there was something where they wanted to do something under the paw
of the Sphinx.
They had found some chamber
that's a needed,
that's a needed project,
which needed,
which needs to be done.
I don't know.
I know whether the new authorities
to right now Egypt is just so busy surviving and so busy,
so busy trying to figure out where it goes next.
And um,
you know,
they've had a major political change.
Um,
but many of the old guard are still in place in many,
many ways.
And a,
there is this popular uprising in Egypt,
but it's disorganized and unplanned it.
So right now the last thing that most Egyptians are thinking about is,
um,
is ancient history take on that part of the world as a comedian is that if
that's the birthplace of civilization,
that's the cradle of civilization that those people right now,
that's the townies of the world.
Yeah.
That's the people that never left the people that literally are living like with
the,
the echoes of the behavior of people that live 10,000 years ago on that very
same spot.
Yeah.
That's why in particular,
Egypt's Coptic population who'd number out of 60 million,
I believe,
roughly 6 million our cops.
So they are,
they are practicing a particularly ancient form of Christianity.
They're language is structurally very closely related to the ancient Egyptian
language and they are the direct inheritors of the ancient Egyptian tradition.
So when ancient Egyptians were converted to Christianity roundabout three or 400
years after Christ,
um,
that was the beginning of the Coptic church in,
in ancient Egypt.
And the Coptic people are the true inheritors of the lost wisdom.
Fascinating and ancient Dj.
And I bet they suck to hang out with,
but they're really annoying.
But they've got some crazy rules.
They do a lot of weird stuff to their people.
Well,
they could,
they do.
They are they involved in general population now?
Really?
There's two ways to get there.
A persecuted minority.
Yeah.
Very,
very much.
6 million of them.
But out of 60 million and in an area which is,
um,
which is involved with Islamic fundamentalism are very much,
it's difficult to be a minority in that situation.
So what you're saying,
it's better.
It's better to be a Christian in that area.
No,
I,
I think that all three of the world's monotheistic faiths,
whether it's Christianity,
Judaism,
or Islam have been responsible for just a vast amount of misery in the world.
And I think if we're not going to move on as a human race,
unless we actually move on from that time where we don't,
we don't accept that something is true just because our parents or some guy with
a beard tells us that it's true.
You know,
we look for direct experience of the spirit and the divine.
This is the problem with all of those big religions.
I don't care whether they call themselves Christians,
Muslims or Jews,
you know,
is that there are hierarchies,
their bureaucracies that power structures and uh,
they do not offer a direct experience of that.
That's why all of them persecute the use of psychedelics.
They don't want people to have direct contact with the divine or you,
I'm hopeful about things when you see like Arab spring,
people were rising up and trying to remove dictators and what happened in Egypt,
getting rid of Mubarak.
And I am hopeful and I think it's,
I think it is happening all over the world and I think the Internet has played a
part with it and it's happening in America.
Um,
you know,
I,
I come here as a,
as a foreigner,
I'm British.
I come to,
I come to America.
Awesome.
Um,
I have family here in America.
I feel very closely connected with America.
And America is a paradox.
You know,
it's a huge paradox because on the world's stage,
uh,
America is a very dark and malignant force,
which,
uh,
which does tremendous harm,
consistently and has done for it for a long time.
But at the individual level,
there's a tremendous spirit of awakening in America.
Look,
just what's happening with cannabis laws in America in the last,
in the last 10 years,
that's unimaginable in Britain.
We can't make changes like that because we don't have this spirit of
independence.
We don't have the structure where individual states can make decisions on key
issues like that.
And,
and of course in America that there's a conflict between state law and federal
law.
You know,
the federal government is not always respecting state laws and is seeking to
persecute people who are,
who are using cannabis.
But you know,
I think that that in itself,
the fact that a number of states have decriminalized or even legalized cannabis,
uh,
is a sign of a,
a sea change that is underway at the moment and what it reflects is an awakening
of the American people.
So even though,
you know,
huge negative forces are still at work and I was still sitting in the seat of
power,
I think,
I think there's a tremendous hope for the future in America.
And that comes from the,
the,
the awakening to consciousness of the American people.
And maybe it's small right now,
but it's growing.
And in that sense,
far more than any other,
I believe America is leading the world.
That there is this possibility for awakening here.
And maybe it goes back to the founding fathers and the frontier days and just
that the,
the,
the sense that that people should be able to make decisions about their own
lives without government telling them what to do.
That's the step we all need to take.
We need to move ahead.
We need to set aside our commitment to these large monolithic religions.
We need to set aside our commitment to large,
monolithic states.
We need to run our own lives and make decisions for ourselves and it just
happens that that is very close to the heart of what America is all about.
Would,
it should be all about
we're living inside of the balls and the Dick that's fucking the world.
Yeah.
That's really what it's all about.
Living inside the balls.
You're in a position to give that dig this fucking the world a real well without
even better is if the deck would just get shit together.
Yeah.
It's,
it's all going to be done by the American people or the by the,
by the awakening of the American people.
And they will say,
enough is enough and we will not accept this crap anymore.
And slowly but surely the old guard dies off or,
and then there's huge industry of brainwashing which goes on,
makes it difficult for people to think for themselves.
Um,
you know,
it's very washing.
Like how well through the media,
I mean just through,
through the,
through the controls.
So there's this whole ethic that our lives,
I suppose to be about production and consumption and nothing else that we define
ourselves in terms of what we owed.
We're prepared to go into huge debt to own a shiny car or you know,
a better house and,
and uh,
that's supposed to be right and proper.
And,
and,
and then we're supposed to,
we define ourselves in terms of our consumption.
Uh,
and we must work hard.
We must go to the office every day.
We must all of these,
all of these things are brainwashing.
And then,
and then there's the TV.
We can have a little relaxation,
we can enjoy some fantasy,
maybe we'll win the lottery one day.
All of these are mechanisms of control,
which,
which keep people quiet in society and distraction.
Yeah.
Distractions from the great beyond.
It's just there's too much out there to really stop and think about the fact
that your body's going to slowly expire.
Even the sun that heats the world itself is going to die out.
And I think the possibilities when we really consider them all are pretty
terrifying.
So we watched storage wars,
you know,
do you have storage warrants?
No.
One of the best shows ever.
Not really.
It's terrible.
But I mean it's hilarious.
They go to storage units that people haven't paid for and they open up the door
and they find things in there and like,
Whoa,
what is this?
And they bid on the door.
Like if there's like 10 people sitting around and they all bid on the contents
and if you get lucky,
who knows?
It might be gold bullying in there that someone saved or not.
So these idiots go and open up these boxes and then pull shit out.
And then it turns out that it's not even really what the contents were.
They added fake contents to these storage places.
Right.
But people watch it.
Yeah.
They just stay distracted.
It's a distraction.
So,
so if we're going to wake up,
um,
we have to overthrow these systems of mental control,
which are,
which are in place
take responsibility for your own time.
Because those,
those distractions are just their money extractors.
That's what they are.
They're all money,
their own money.
They're selling tide or Toyota trucks or whatever the hell they're selling.
Yeah.
And you know,
they're just putting on this thing cause that's,
it's a,
it's a machine that they can press and it just,
it's like an automatic program that runs and extracts money.
It's not really necessarily a work of art.
It's just,
you know,
you've made a hack,
terrifying prospect,
but it doesn't,
you don't have to do it.
You know,
I think what people really need is what,
you know,
it sounds crazy,
but people really need is guys like you to talk about things guys like you to
put ideas out there that makes them go,
yeah,
what am I doing?
Yeah,
what is this and what is and start the ball rolling of rethinking their,
their thoughts.
Yes,
rethinking is a badly needed.
It's everything,
right?
It's everything.
And I do and I do think that it's something that I bang on about a lot is the
issue of sovereignty over consciousness.
That is to me just one of the very,
very,
very key issues which a lot a lot of people have been persuaded not ever to
think about.
But once you start thinking about it,
you realize that this mysterious,
and we don't even know what consciousness is,
you know,
I mean there is no,
there is no clear science on what it is or,
or to explain it.
But we know we've got it and whatever it is,
it's the essence of ourselves.
And why can we not make sovereign decisions over the most intimate and personal
part of ourselves as crazy.
And,
and when I find when you put that to put that to people,
even even to arch Republicans,
you know,
they get it,
they suddenly realize,
you know,
that even,
um,
that,
that they actually legal legalizing psychedelics is a republican issue.
I'll tell you what the problem is,
Graham Hancock is the children where you're,
you're ignoring is Yuri endorsing drug use to children.
And I think that's incredibly irresponsible.
That's exactly what Ted said when they banned my tool.
What did that statements,
they said that we can't allow this talk to be on the air because some young man
might go off to South America and drink IOWASCA that's so hilariously bad.
CanNot be seen to be endorsing the drinking of Iowa.
Is that the what?
There wasn't a huge issue with you.
And by the way,
your issue was after Eddie Wong came in here and as long told his gross story
that makes you just go,
oh,
ted.
Apparently John Anthony West has a 10 story as well.
Um,
and I think that there's,
uh,
a lot of beautiful things had come out of tech,
a lot of incredible tools,
but it seems like any organization,
once people get into power and once people have the ability to tell other people
what's cool and what's not cool,
it starts getting weird and you start telling Eddie Wong he has to attend all
these different things and meet all these donors and like some kind of freaky
cult.
Yeah.
Well that's what he felt like.
You felt like it was really strange.
Now your,
your thing got pulled.
And what was the scientific explanation for why they got polled?
Um,
was there,
was you,
you had an exchange with one of the guys on Ted.
I read the comments and you presented all the things that he had said and said,
please show your example of when I said this,
I never said this.
What were the various,
what was the thing that he accused you of and what was the response?
Got Our talks deleted.
Rupert Sheldrake sheltering is the other,
his toe,
it was called the science delusion might talk,
was called the war on consciousness.
He can't be shitting on science like that called the science to illusion.
Rupert,
how dare you poked it was as though it was as though
Ted felt that these talks must automatically be wrong and that they had some
kind of preconception about what we were saying.
So they didn't even bother to sit down and listen to the actual 18 minute talks,
not that much to listen to,
you know,
before deleting it from their youtube channel.
They just said this is pseudoscience.
Uh,
it's full of,
and they listed a series of false statements that we'd supposedly made,
but the problem was neither I nor Rupert had made those statements.
So they never even bothered to look at it.
They just read complaints and then responding.
None of
the basis of those.
So when we challenged them,
okay,
please go through in my case,
go through my talk and,
and find where I say that Iowasca allows you to communicate with an ancient
mother culture.
Where do I say that?
I never,
that in my talk,
I never said any such thing in my talk.
They actually couldn't do it.
And,
and something you've said before?
No,
I've never seen that.
I've never said that right now.
I heard you.
What I talked about was the mother got,
or the experience of an encounter with a man that God is,
but I never said it allows you to communicate with an ancient mother culture,
like a lost civilization.
They knew I had written books about lost civilizations,
so they thought I must be bringing the,
my lost civilization beef into the,
into my ted talk,
which I did.
And it didn't have anything to do with lost civilization.
It was a talk about,
talk about consciousness anyway.
And the real,
the original version was giving up the green bitch where you were talking to
recently.
I originally called the talk,
giving up the Greens.
I watch shows because I was giving my personal story of,
of,
uh,
you know,
why I,
why I gave up her cannabis.
Um,
I changed that title because a lot of people pointed out to me that that's
deeply disrespectful of cannabis and that for many people,
cannabis is a green goddess and cannabis was a green goddess for me.
And I accepted that.
So that got to those people,
I'd say fucking relax.
Okay.
Cause I love cannabis.
To me,
it didn't bother me.
People got really upset.
I realized that to be absurd,
I realized that there is in fact a cannabis orthodoxy as well,
which I wish my wish by talking about my,
my,
my quitting of cannabis,
I hit upset this orthodoxy.
But when I looked at my talk,
my talk was much more about the war on consciousness than it was about that.
And that's what it was really about.
So for example,
I made the point that,
um,
our society doesn't object in principle to altering consciousness.
I mean,
what happens when you put a kid on Ritalin?
You know,
that's a powerful pharmacological drug,
which is altering consciousness when you win,
you over prescribed Prozac or Ciroc sat for conditions of depression that those
drugs are altering consciousness.
We value alcohol.
We invest,
you know,
have multibillion dollar alcohol industry.
People don't primarily Rick drink alcohol because of the taste.
They drink it because it alters their consciousness in a way that they like.
And,
and so we don't object to altering consciousness in principle,
but we object to altering consciousness in certain kinds of ways which threaten
the status quo.
And that's what psychedelics do.
They alter consciousness in ways that lead people to ask profound questions
about the nature of the society they live in.
And that appears to be the line that I crossed.
So Ted tied to try to dress it up as pseudoscience.
And when I called them on that in the end because they realized I think that
they were,
they'd got themselves into some kind of danger and it's still there on the,
on the webpage that w Rupert and I call it,
they're naughty corner,
they created a naughty corner of the Ted website where I've talked to him quick
back on line and with all their reasons why they've taken them off.
So first thing they did was they crossed out all their reasons.
So you can find that everything they said has actually been crossed out.
And then they published our rebuttals completely.
We know,
we insisted that they accepted that nothing they'd said was true,
but we insisted they leave it there.
On the public record,
but put a line through it.
Oh Wow.
So that,
so that they did,
they did that.
They did that.
Oh my God,
they did that and then they of a cool victory.
I know,
I know.
And they published our rebuttals in full,
but it wasn't a complete victory because what they didn't do,
which is all we wanted was for our talks to burry it reinstated on the TEDX
youtube channel.
No,
no,
no.
Only that.
But you can't put your tea,
your talk online yourself.
Well,
no,
I've,
I have put my talk on line myself and [inaudible] so have about a hundred other
youtube channels.
And I think Ted took such a massive beating over this for a big,
because it clearly was an act of censorship.
However,
they tried to dress it up that they've decided not to go and pull,
uh,
the talks from,
from Youtube,
which probably probably they could do.
So,
I mean,
my talk had 132,000 views on youtube on their channel when they pulled it.
But since then it's had hundreds of thousands of more views all over the
internet.
So,
you know,
they the,
rather than actually suppress the talk,
I think it's called the Streisand effect,
you know,
rather than suppress the talks,
they ended up multiplying.
Same but same with customers apparently.
Apparently the,
I think it was by Australia and tried to stop some public statement that had
been made about her and it ended up multiplying the statement.
You know,
when you try it,
this is the great thing about the Internet.
When you try to suppress something,
it grows,
it doesn't get suppressed.
The Internet is sucking Dick Pictures.
One of those out there come back around Graham Hancock.
I'm going to find you.
I've never had my dick photograph.
Congratulations.
How about you
plead the fifth?
Um,
so now the,
the,
the page got polled your,
your talk on polled it got reinstated.
They crossed a line and put up in the naughty corner.
But at least it's on youtube as well.
And um,
is it possible that this is what I know?
Okay.
I,
uh,
I really love your work.
I've been a fan ever since,
uh,
fingerprints of the gods.
It was a fascinating book that really changed the way I looked at history there.
I think you're a brilliant guy,
but I take more shit for,
for you from the like six streams,
science dorks.
I take more shit about having you.
Well it's Bram Hancock gonna come on your podcast and in pump out his pseudo
science.
It's like so many people get so twatty about you and it's a science thing and it
could be mistakes that you've made in the past.
We all make them that they want to Chirp on.
Uh,
it could be the whole Mars thing,
the whole face on Mars think I look cookie with that kind of look cookie with
that.
Still think it's an interesting phenomena.
It is interesting.
There's a lot of interesting rocks on Mars.
It,
it might have at one point in time how to culture.
I don't know what they are.
No,
we need to need to do we need to do more work,
but yeah,
I do.
I haven't,
no,
I'd scientists,
I tell you what,
it's not actually.
I,
I've certainly made mistakes.
Right?
What about a junk DNA?
There was,
uh,
something about,
the contents of junk DNA.
That's one thing that they keep harping,
erroneously stated,
you know,
something about the knowledge that we have of junk DNA.
Well,
uh,
yes,
I said that 97% of DNA is defined as and,
and uh,
maybe it isn't.
Um,
and that,
uh,
there may be data stored on DNA.
Um,
and as a matter of fact that this is now being done,
data is being stored on DNA.
Um,
misinformed.
I don't think that I was misinformed.
I think that I was exploring an interesting,
an interesting area of inquiry.
That's true since I published on that in 2005 that some new workers could have
been done on junk so called junk DNA and it is found to have,
uh,
an important bio physical function.
Um,
but what I,
what I reported,
and this was in my book supernatural in 2005 was a study published in the
magazine science by Eugene Stanley.
Um,
which looked at the language like structure of junk DNA.
The junk DNA has a structure,
a very similar to all human languages.
There are certain patterns that repeat in languages that appear also in junk
DNA.
Um,
and this I simply wanted to speculate on this.
Is it possible that junk DNA is some kind of archive?
I was looking,
you know,
in when I wrote supernatural,
I was looking at this connection with entities that people have in altered
states of consciousness.
And,
and I were saying that kind of place I would bet on is that in some weird way
these entities may be real.
That is in itself a very annoying statement to make to any materials scientist,
right?
But then I said,
well,
maybe there's another possibility.
Maybe there's a,
an archive of information stored on all our DNA all around the world.
And maybe in altered states of consciousness,
we gain access to the archive.
And that's maybe why people from all different cultures at different periods of
history see the same thing.
And I cited the work of Francis Crick who was the discoverer of the double helix
form of DNA,
uh,
in a book that he wrote called life itself,
where Crick speculates that DNA did not evolve on this planet.
This is the,
this is the Nobel Prize winner,
Francis Crick.
This is not Graham Hancock who is making the statement,
crikey suggests a phenomenon called directed Panspermia that,
uh,
that the reason that life exploded so rapidly and amazingly on this planet
within a hundred million years of the planet being cool enough to support life
roughly 4 billion years ago,
the reason that it exploded so suddenly was that he came here from elsewhere and
he suggested that there had been some advanced alien culture on the other side
of the galaxy that faced annihilation.
Perhaps a supernova was going to go off in their vicinity and they look
desperately for some way to preserve life.
And their first thought was could they get themselves off the planet?
And they realized that yes they could,
but that they could not travel through interstellar space for thousands or
millions of years to reach other possibly habitable planets.
So in the end,
what they did was they sent bacteria out into the universe on space ships and
they genetically engineered those bacteria to make incredibly hardy.
This was cricks suggestion,
not mine.
And the only thing you got to really say that the only thing I added to it was
if they,
if his theory had bit were right and that life spiraled up on this planet
because one of those spaceships hit the ancient earth and spilled out it's cargo
of genetically engineered bacteria.
Well maybe they wrote a message on the DNA of those bacteria and maybe that
message has been preserved,
highly preserved.
And there are certain strands of DNA that are preserved for for hundreds of
millions or billions of years and passed down into modern human beings.
And maybe it's a message for us about that last ancestor culture that made the
DNA that,
or rather didn't make it,
but engineered the DNA in the bacteria that started life on earth.
And that eventually evolved into us.
And it was just an interesting inquiry as this lends credence to the idea of
Francis Crick did a lot of acid,
why would,
she certainly did Francis Crick,
I'm denying this,
Michio Kaku wouldn't agree with me on us.
Francis Crick was a big user of acid and,
and so we're posing alleged.
So were many intellectuals in that period.
This is essentially the Prometheans story I guess.
A lot of ways.
Yeah,
I guess it,
I guess it is.
So I thought it was an interesting area to inquire.
Quite simple.
For me.
I feel my,
my role is to inquire into interesting things that are forbidden territory for
scientists.
And when I inquire into them,
it doesn't mean that I'm insisting this is a fact.
It me,
what I'm saying is this is something that we need an alternative point of view
on and let's look at and consider what this,
what this might mean.
And I may be completely wrong,
but I think the exploration is worthwhile.
That's the,
that's the position that I take.
It doesn't know sides.
I think the other reason it annoys scientists is because,
um,
I don't mean to pat myself on the back,
but I'm,
I'm not particularly lunatic,
you know,
on a day to day basis.
I'm not particularly cookie.
I'm moderately rational.
I can make an argument,
I can express things.
And,
and I think if I was,
you know,
an obvious nutcase,
they wouldn't need to get so angry with me.
But because,
because I'm fairly,
I'm fairly reasonable and open to discussion and persuasion,
I think it makes me,
it makes me more a little bit more dangerous to them.
And it's the same with John Anthony West.
John is a very reasonable man.
You know,
he's coming out with extraordinary ideas about the past.
Uh,
but he's arguing them very,
very well and very coherently and based on based on evidence,
intellectual ideas also are the battlefield of scientists and science thinkers
in science dorks.
Me Proving someone incorrect is a huge feather in your cap.
Being able to point out inconsistencies in correcting mistakes and that's how
science works and that's what's,
that's what's great about it.
Yes.
On the one had,
it's what's good about science,
which is what what you would call destructive criticism.
Here is a new idea.
Let's figure out any way we can to destroy it.
Anything is left after we've exposed it to that fire for a decade.
That thing that's left
is probably worthwhile.
That's,
and that's,
that is the scientific method.
I think there's room for another method.
Here's this extraordinary idea that somebody put over,
let's look for what's good in that idea.
Let's see if we can find something good in that.
Yeah.
See,
to see if there's something possible approach just in a positive way,
just in a positive way rather than,
uh,
rather than a negative way.
So.
Right.
You know,
I think,
I think that both are,
both are both are possible.
It's the same attitude essentially.
You're trying to find truth.
Yeah.
It just,
you're saying,
uh,
is,
is there,
is there a possibility of this,
is there a truth in here?
Yeah.
And is there a benefit?
Like that's what a real egyptologist would do if they examine the spanx.
They would say,
you know,
this really bare some consideration.
This is really unique.
It's unusual.
I end geologists seemed to be pointing to this,
let's,
let's discuss this on this,
spread that rather than just get rid of it right at the beginning of massively
destroy culture.
Or are we talking about from 10,000 years ago?
Exactly.
And so with this destructive methods,
scientists seek to destroy each other's reputations.
And so,
you know,
many,
many great individuals have suffered most painful experiences as a result of
this,
but have ended up later to be proved to be right.
Sometimes,
sometimes,
sometimes not.
It's not quacks out there too and they need to be exposed.
One of the things I've,
I'm doing this new show on the Scifi channel,
it's called Joe Rogan questions everything.
And uh,
eventually,
uh,
where I would like to get to the mysteries of ancient civilizations and whether
or not there were some sort of Atlantean type civilization.
I would love to talk to you about this.
But what,
what I'm seeing when I'm doing this show is how important science really is.
I'm getting an a massive dose of the reality of how many people are really Kooky
out there and have some really kooky ideas that they cling to like a cat stuck
in a tree or Cody's fucking cookie ideas.
And no matter how many experts you bring in there that are true experts on
whatever subject it is at hand.
If that person has a Kooky idea that they've clung to,
they are not letting that fucking thing go.
That's why science is so important.
Science is,
science is incredibly important.
It's the ego and pride.
It's a pride.
I'm sitting here in this chair where the painfree hip as a result of science.
Yeah,
that is science.
Science gave me my legs back.
Science gave me my mobility sciences,
how we're doing this.
Podcast science is how we're doing this podcast.
It's a,
it's a wonderful thing.
It's an incredible instrument.
We should not despise it in itself,
but we should I think,
be open to the view that there are other modes of inquiry into the nature of
reality,
which should be also considered.
It could even be done,
done,
done scientifically.
Uh,
for example,
psychedelics are a marvelous tool for inquiring into consciousness,
this mystery of consciousness.
And we could have detailed scientific study.
So he has the hypothesis with psychedelics.
We reach you in the receiver wavelength of the brain and gate hypothesis.
Mind you and gain
access to other levels of reality,
parallel universes if you like,
which are inhabited by intelligent beings.
Okay,
let's explore that hypothesis scientifically.
How are we going to do that?
Psychedelics?
Very best way.
Put people into deeply altered states of consciousness on cue,
you know,
and then get them to compare notes,
get them to ask questions of those entities,
see if any new information,
any novel information comes back that couldn't possibly have been known.
You know,
that that kind of thing is being done.
Interestingly with near death research,
um,
uh,
there,
there is,
you know,
there's another area where most materialist mainstream scientists,
we'll say nonsense,
there's no possibility of any kind of survival of death,
but people report these astonishing near death experiences and they report a
seeing things that they should not have been able to see.
So now in operating theaters,
in emergency rooms,
uh,
in a number of hospitals in London,
but also I believe in the United States as well,
they have created shelves up at a high level where they have placed certain
images and,
uh,
they are recording the data right now.
When people have a near death experience and they have had the sense of leaving
their bodies and being up around the ceiling.
Have they seen these images?
If they've seen those images and it can be documented scientifically,
then you know,
we have to think again about consciousness.
So they're putting the images up there specifically to catch people looking.
Yeah.
So when the guy comes back,
when he flat lines and he's considered to be brain dead and they bring him back
to life,
this is happening more and more with advanced resuscitation techniques.
Many of them report having experiences out of their body.
Well now here's a scientific way to test that.
Is that imagination or is there something real going on
and what's the data so far,
if people seen those images of they had,
there's some,
there's some
quite compelling,
there's some quite compelling data,
but there's an elusive nature to the phenomenon,
which is that very often when somebody has a near death experience,
they've had it in the vault,
the one theater that didn't have the images on view.
So they're looking,
they're looking for a convenient,
how convenient.
They're looking for a way round this,
which might involve using a like iPad devices,
which can be moved around very rapidly and placed in certain certain spots
where the resuscitating resuscitating people,
I don't think,
see,
I think this is part of the issue.
You know,
when we say why doesn't science do this?
Or what if science did that?
I really don't think it's science.
I think science and the scientific method are awesome and very hugely important.
I think it's people.
Yeah.
I think the issue is people,
it's personalities.
It's people's style of communication.
It's people's styles of interaction and there the sense of competition that they
have with exchanging ideas and with exploring ideas.
Yeah.
It's a massive amount of competition involved in being intellectually correct.
Getting those points,
the points for being correct,
right.
It's a competition for them.
I mean,
I,
I've seen it on my message board.
I've seen on reddit there's,
when you're writing something,
you're not just writing something.
Also sort of expressing yourself in a way that you would like to get Brownie
points for that you would like to be powerful.
Good name,
mapping it to what you say.
Right.
We would like,
you would like people we all want to be like,
so when people go to battle about ideas,
the real issue is ego.
It's humans.
It's not the scientific method,
which the scientific method should most certainly be applied to psychedelics.
It should most certainly be applied to every aspect of the known world.
Yeah.
And in fact if that was the case then more people would probably do psychedelics
and we'd have less of an issue in the first place.
I would rather,
I would rather think so.
So you're,
you're not an anti science guy,
you just an anti asshole guy.
Thank you.
That's a good way to put it,
I think.
But there's a label that people like to throw on you that you are anti
scientific and I think that's one of the ways that this ted thing built momentum
and when,
yeah,
they do,
they do like to throw that label.
As a matter of fact,
pseudoscience.
it's one of the reasons amongst many why I started to write fiction as well as
nonfiction.
Because if I explore extraordinary ideas in the realm of fiction,
I'm not actually then making a claim that this is fact.
Nevertheless,
the ideas are there to be explored in what,
in what I've written.
So it becomes,
it becomes possible to enter into an inquiry,
into the nature of reality without having to create this huge superstructure of
defense,
uh,
against attacks by,
by scientists.
And I think it's a very useful way forward as far as,
as far as I'm concerned,
because I did find that writing,
um,
the writing nonfiction,
uh,
more and more because I've become this target figure for scientists required me
to bulletproof my arguments in ways that make them,
frankly,
a bit boring to read,
you know?
And,
and I'm,
I quite like the liberation of not having to do that.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think your,
your ideas are always very novel and you're very interesting dude.
But I think in a lot of ways you're sort of a barred,
you know,
you,
you're a great storyteller and you're an exciter of the imagination and in
inspire of questions.
Thank you.
I feel that's what I'm supposed to do.
That's what you do best man.
That book,
fingerprints of the Gods got me looking at so many different aspects of our
culture and then questioning how we got to this point in the first place.
How it is that I get up in the morning,
I get in my car and I drive to work as it was doing this after reading your
book,
I was thinking how strange it is that we live in this society where I was born
in 1967.
Um,
I was,
you know,
we've this,
the cities have been here since I was a baby.
Cars had been here.
I have assumed that they've always been here.
But then when you really stop and think about what a short period of time,
2,500 BC is or what a short period of time,
even 30,000 BC is.
Yeah.
Well,
that's nothing man in the history of the world.
It's all a a blink.
Yes,
it's a nothing.
And we are in the middle of this.
We wake up,
it being born is like waking up in the middle of a trip.
Like where are we?
Where are we going?
And that's the entire collective culture.
And that was really probably the first time I've ever really considered that was
in reading your book.
And that made me so excited about history.
I wasn't excited about history from school.
I mean,
I took the obligatory classes,
glad to have had that,
to have had that effect.
And it makes me feel good as,
as I'm getting on in life.
One of the things that makes me feel good is this,
the feedback that I do get from people who've read my books,
which I've sweated blood in order to,
to write.
And I've taken a lot of,
uh,
attacks,
from doing that.
But I find this the new thing for me.
Um,
you know,
Facebook,
I mean I,
I'm a novice at Facebook,
but I've started to interact really quite strongly on my Facebook pages.
I enjoy the interaction that I get there.
I enjoy,
uh,
the new ideas that are put to me by,
by others.
Um,
and uh,
yeah.
Uh,
frankly,
it's really nice when,
when some,
some kid in his 20s,
right writes to me and says he red fingerprints of the gods and it changed the
way that he looks at the world.
I've,
that,
that makes me feel I've done something.
I've done something,
right.
Anyway,
in all the mistakes I may have made,
I've done,
I've done something
you've done quite a bit,
right?
But one of the things I think that you,
you,
you haven't done yet that you could totally be amazing at is do your own
podcast.
You're a windup guy.
I can press you,
I can start you up.
Tell what,
what,
what's this Iowasca stuff?
Bang,
press play.
And you will,
you will do the dance and,
and captivate with amazing descriptions and this very,
uh,
in,
in trancing and way of communicating.
Interesting.
I think that's the,
the people like that are really important in culture and most scientists are
boring as fuck.
And even though they're doing amazing work and it's,
we wouldn't be communicating if it wasn't for some boring scientist.
The reality is you're not going to excite people with that shitty personality of
yours.
Yeah.
And it's not all of them.
Let me find one.
Was legendarily charismatic,
there's some great guys crossing again,
you know,
Neil degrasse Tyson is brilliant in that regard.
He's a,
he's a brilliant man and he's brilliant,
is captivating and entertaining and he draws you in and they're very important
as well,
are important as well.
There's a lot of,
uh,
well I will look at the,
um,
podcast my friend
now that I have now that I've kind of initiated myself into the Internet world
and got talking to people on Facebook and so on and my website,
you know,
all of these things our way.
And the one thing I haven't done,
I do have a youtube channel,
but what I don't have is,
uh,
is,
is a podcast and it might be some
massively important,
it's the best way to communicate with people because even in writing,
sometimes things are lost in tone and tone.
And the way you can be sarcastic and just joking around,
you actually have to write it.
Just kidding.
You know,
you have to actually quantify it.
Whereas people know in the inflection of your voice,
the look on your face.
That's why we'd like do this.
You,
even though most of the people listen to this podcast,
we like to have an iTunes version so you could see sometimes we're making silly
faces were joking around.
Um,
I think for you it would be an excellent way to explore new ideas,
the things that come to you and also respond to people online instead of like
sitting down and writing everything out.
Pick a few emails every week and respond to them.
And
I will take your advice.
Perfect.
For you,
what was the argument against Rupert Sheldrake from what I've read online was a
bit stronger than the argument for you?
No,
I don't think so.
Again,
they attributed statements to him that he didn't make,
so it was more of the same type of same type of thing.
He,
he,
his,
uh,
controversial,
well,
he's saying that that scientist science is locked in what we call a materialist
reference frame,
which is that it seeks to reduce everything to matter and that there cannot be.
And so therefore,
the idea of telepathy,
for example,
is an impossible idea as far as mainstream science is concerned.
Because if your consciousness is simply something that's generated by your brain
way,
how can you then pick up the thoughts of somebody else,
you know,
across a continent or,
or on the other side of the world.
How is that,
how is that possible?
Um,
and,
uh,
so he,
he was,
he is questioning the materialist reference frame of mainstream science.
And since the most vocal advocates of mainstream science are materialists who do
it,
they do believe that consciousness is an accidental epi phenomenon of brain
activity.
That there is nothing,
there is nothing else to it than that he got under a lot of skin.
Well,
there's also the one that don't believe that.
And having clearly defined what consciousness is,
but say if psychic abilities do exist,
show them yeah.
Exhibit them.
Well,
that's precisely what [inaudible] has done.
Okay.
Yes.
But what has he done clearly that shows,
um,
in your opinion?
Well,
for,
for example,
um,
documenting the sense of being stared at that people,
people know when they're being right and he's done experiments which document
this and prove it at a level of statistical significance.
Got a couple of percent,
right.
Couple of percent.
Why does your dog know when you're coming home?
Has that been disproven ever?
No.
Even though the owner of the dog varies,
the root comes home by a different route in a different way.
Um,
everything might be your wife.
Yeah,
that's probably [inaudible].
Hello?
Oh,
it's your neighbor.
Oh yeah,
she's here.
Okay.
We'll have someone come out and get it right now.
Thank you very much.
All right,
Jamie,
just go out and tell her we'll wrap this up.
That's our neighbor.
Yeah.
She must've been knocking on the door.
The great
thing about a live,
a live discussion.
It's beautiful.
Ted's up at the door and she's,
she's got a telephone.
It's cool because people
know that it's not some etiquette,
you know,
uh,
it's not edited and polished.
It's a,
it's a real conversation.
And that way,
you know,
like we couldn't have this conversation afterwards and he'd say,
ah,
you know,
the thing about science,
maybe I said something,
could we,
could we cut that out?
No,
it's role.
It's real and uh,
and,
and it works.
Um,
can I,
can I say a couple of things which I would like people to hear?
Sure.
One is,
um,
I this,
this is an odd thing to ask because I've been very,
I've been very successful as a nonfiction author,
but,
but I am hoping that people will pay attention to my fiction and that people
will listen to my fiction.
It's very,
very difficult for me to be published as a novelist.
The publishing industry want me to stay in my box as a successful nonfiction
author and they don't want me to explore the fictional side of things.
So I've managed to get a British publisher for my novel,
which we talked about earlier,
War God,
about the Spanish conquest of Mexico.
But so far I don't have an American publisher and I have been helped a lot by my
Facebook community,
many of whom are Americans who have gone to Amazon UK and bought the British
edition of my book.
I'm from America and it will be delivered to them here in America,
uh,
in a few days because the book is published on the 30th of May.
And if anybody's interested in that story,
I would appreciate if they'd make the effort to go to Amazon UK and pick up the
book.
Because what that does then is it gives the book the possibility of some success
in Britain and if it succeeds in Britain,
then it will be picked up by an American publisher.
The resistance is just that it's nonfiction.
Yeah,
that's right.
Publishing,
publishing industries and industry that thinks in terms of brands,
and I am branded as a nonfiction author.
This is your second [inaudible] is my second.
There's a second.
So when I first novel vanished without a trace because it had,
that was called entangled because it had absolutely no support from,
from the publishers at all.
It's sold a few thousand copies.
But really it was,
it was completely ignored.
And the same thing is going to happen with,
uh,
with war God as well.
Um,
and,
and less if people find it.
And now what I've done is I've put free chapters,
free to read chapters online on my website and be very as Graham hancock.com.
That's www dot Graham Hancock dot.
Yeah,
we've got to fix her Twitter,
man.
Double underscore is confusing,
but I can't,
I couldn't get that name.
I couldn't get at Graham Hancock.
I got at Graham.
Who's Graham Hancock?
Who's the at Graham Hancock?
Well,
there's another guy with my name and his name is Graham Hancock.
His name is Greg [inaudible].
He got it first.
So nothing can be,
not just a double underscore.
Couldn't you just do something else like Graham Hancock in one word?
No,
that's what he's got.
He's got it.
Oh,
well how about,
uh,
did you have a middle name?
Gray and brief sign code?
Granby Hancock.
Yeah.
Well,
how about that?
No,
that's stupid.
Yeah,
I forgot it.
I forgot what I was saying.
Yeah.
You know,
my,
my mother bless her when she gave me my name [inaudible] she had him.
So my initials are [inaudible] Hancock.
Okay.
Right when she gave me my name,
she,
she was thinking of yeah.
That,
that's,
that's what I use on my email address.
She was thinking about you fucked up,
someone's going to hit you with email and hit me with emails anyway.
It's okay.
She was thinking in a rather grandiose way of George Bernard Shaw,
you know,
Gb.
Oh.
So she called me Gb hung and not realizing that Gbh also stands for grievous
bodily harm,
you know.
Oh,
it does.
In Briston in British law.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a particular,
that's a particular crime.
You know,
that you've committed an act of grievance of Gbh somebody.
So that's my,
that's,
that's my initials.
I don't know what to,
um,
what to do about my Twitter name.
Maybe we'll just have to keep it stable and just double underscore this is,
so there's an underscore.
Can I introduce my Sottha?
Sure.
If she wants to stop,
come here.
Hi Samantha.
Hi.
What's up?
Okay.
He's all so happy now that he quit.
Quit.
We'd look at them completely.
Yes.
Are you happier?
Nobody quit weekly.
Wow.
Thank God.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
No,
because it's simply because he was abusing this sounds right.
It is.
Yeah.
I understand.
It was the substance controlling him being in control of him as opposed to him.
Yeah.
Shell of the substances.
We went deep into it.
Yeah.
It's interesting stuff.
Do you have this on?
Um,
Kendall?
Uh,
yes,
but you have to buy it in England and I think there's some things that make it
difficult for Americans to buy the kindle edition.
They can only,
they can only buy,
they're the hard,
the hardback edition [inaudible] still.
But there's,
there's links on my website which go to the right place to buy it and those
chapters to read so people can meet.
I'm not asking people to buy it.
Blind people can make up their own minds.
Read chapters.
If they hate it,
don't buy it.
Graham Hancock,
one of our sponsors is audible.com is audible.com.
Yeah.
Do you do?
You might not know.
The US edition of my first novel entangled is available on audible,
but right now I do not have,
did you read it?
Huh?
No,
I did it.
It was red,
but it was right by somebody else.
Yeah.
Do you like the person who read it?
Is it good?
It's gotta be weird or hearing someone read your words.
It's weird.
Um,
if they don't do it well,
but in this case it was done well.
Wow.
Yeah.
You don't want to buy a Stephen King's when he reads them.
That's the only,
if I were to give advice,
not had that plan.
I'm a huge Stephen King Fan.
Me toward the king is brilliant.
This is amazing.
His he and his book on writing is equally amazing.
And Stephen King on writing,
writing.
All right.
Yeah.
If you are a writer,
there's two books you need the war of art and Stephen King on writing.
Those are the two we want to stay.
Steven,
Steven Pressfield's,
the war,
the war or not and his new one turning pro.
It's equally brilliant.
Yeah.
Plastic.
Don't ever get an audio book that Stephen King reads cause he's fucking boring
as shit.
Okay.
He'll put your right to sleep.
I mean,
the guy's the greatest author ever as far as I'm concerned.
Yeah,
I agree.
he's,
he is,
he is the best.
He writes just a,
just an amazing Marita.
There's amazing stories.
He's got gift.
Fantastic gift of writing a story.
Yeah.
I remember reading some of his stuff and I was a young teenager,
like thinking like,
Jesus,
I shouldn't even be reading this.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Like the,
his descriptions like that,
they bordered on creepy,
like some of the sexual stuff and yeah,
he's in it.
He's just a beast.
Yeah.
But he's also been given a gift by the universe.
Right.
Amazing stories that make you want to keep turning the pages.
And you're right.
His book on writing for anybody who aspires to become a writer,
that is the first place you go.
Is it read Stephen King on writing?
Yeah.
It's a brilliant book.
And he's so forthcoming about all of his trials and struggles and yeah,
he's a,
uh,
amazing,
and that's my favorite kind of movie is,
or his books,
like where it's just fantasy.
I don't need thanks to be real in my fiction.
You know,
I,
I enjoy fiction,
but I don't need to see like a really depressing movie where everybody's got
cancer and Oh my God,
so brilliantly acted,
stop,
entertain me,
make me,
show me an evil car that kills people.
You know,
show me the dude next door neighbor's a werewolf.
I think that's the,
that's the rightest first task.
And the fiction writers first task is to entertain.
Did you,
you mean you said witches in this?
Did you throw some supernatural ship war?
God is,
is full of the supernatural.
And,
and,
and I was able to bounce off the fact because,
um,
the Aztec society has been rightly described as the last magical civilization.
They were,
it,
they were involved in,
in magic and witchcraft in a huge,
in a huge way.
And that,
but they also persecuted,
which is just as European society in the Middle Ages,
persecuted,
which is so they're strong supernatural elements in this,
in this story.
And I,
and,
and in a way I think it's only possible to understand what happened between 15,
19 and 1521 when you take the beliefs in the supernatural into account,
it sounds like they were,
I mean,
what your description of a nation of serial killers is apt text word.
That's what they are.
And here's the thing is he,
I mean my,
my two set central female characters meet in what's called a fattening pen.
So this is what the aspects did.
They,
their human sacrificial victims,
they would,
first of all,
they would fatten them up in,
um,
prisons.
Why would they fatten them?
Because they wanted to present them to the God plump,
desirable.
So they would fatten them for months on end.
And can you imagine living in,
that's your situation.
You've been put in the fattening pen,
they're feeding you this high calorie diet and at a certain date you're going to
be marched up there and have your heart cut out.
But that takes,
that takes some courage to resist.
That's hill to con sacrifice of four days of 80,000 people.
I told that to my friend Steve Rinella.
Noah,
and he didn't even believe me.
Yeah,
10 notch tit land,
by the way.
10 hours.
How do you say it?
[inaudible] club.
That was the ancient name of Mexico City.
You used to be an island in the middle of a lake,
approached by causeways and the temple was called [inaudible].
No,
that's actually 35 miles north of Mexico City.
That's a place that's the pyramid of the Sun,
the Pyramid of the moon and the pyramid of quite soco adol which the Aztecs
revered as the place where men became gods.
That is what,
but they didn't know who made tail to what can't they?
What?
[inaudible] was already remotely ancient when the Aztecs came into the Valley of
Mexico and encountered it.
Pyramid of the sun.
The completion of that was when they killed 80,000
no,
no.
That was the pyramid of the war God,
which is why my novel is called War God,
and that stood out.
That stood in the heart of what is now Mexico City,
and when the Spanish took that city,
the very first thing they did was to take that pyramid apart stone by stone.
Did you see what happen?
And Billy's recently.
Yeah,
so,
so an ancient Mayan pyramid is used as a construction material by some asshole
from who?
Who used diggers to just break down the body of the pyramid and use it to make
roads.
Yeah.
How crazy is,
it kind of sums up everything that's wrong with our culture.
That's not our culture.
Well,
that's the,
that's the place where John McAfee was living.
I referred whole.
Absolutely.
I refer to global culture,
global culture and production and consumption.
Yeah.
It is a,
it was astounding that someone would be willing to do that.
You're destroying an archeological site for just for it's limestone.
Yeah.
Like whoa.
Like that is some short sighted asshole.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
But the way that,
but that doesn't,
that shortsightedness that the pursuit of short term goals,
which might be immediately profitable even though long term massively damaging.
Doesn't that actually completely sum up everything that's wrong with global
culture today.
I mean if you wanted to take one act,
which kind of expresses it,
that would be,
that would be it.
You know you don't think long term.
We don't think in terms of the sacred,
we don't the Amazon jungle,
nobody considers you know when the,
when the,
when it's being exploited as an economic resource,
what that means for our planet in the rot,
in the long run.
If all of those trees come down short term to many might've made out of it long
term.
We're losing the lungs of our planet.
Pattern is the real issue with human beings is our ability to do things in large
numbers.
That would be horrific if we did singularly the diffusion of responsibility that
comes from acting as a corporation or acting as an army or acting were horrific.
Things can be justified because you're only a part of one huge group of people
that are doing these things.
We talked about science.
There's been some interesting science done on exactly that point,
which is that they set it up with actors.
You put a situation where somebody is on the street and they're in jeopardy.
Perhaps a woman is perhaps being attacked.
If there are two or three people walking on the street,
they will almost always intervene to prevent the attack,
but if there's a thousand people walking on the street,
nobody intervenes.
Yeah.
Well,
I think
that happens most of the time it can happen,
but I think a lot of people would intervene.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
I think once one of those weird things,
that is like a psychological principle that gets brought up as a sort of,
as a matter of fact,
I don't necessarily think it's a matter of fact because if I saw someone raping
and I kicked her ass,
but you might try at least
be the the extraordinary exception.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
I think there's a lot of people jump in,
but you hear stories like that all the time where people save someone from this
and you did something there.
I think it's more likely that cowards would walk away if there's a thousand
people,
but they're still at a thousand people who's going to do something as somebody
who realizes we're all in this together.
Loyalty,
right.
I share your faith in the human race.
I think we have amazing potential,
amazing capacity to love,
amazing capacity to give amazing generosity and decency.
That's what I encounter day to day.
Yeah.
For the most part,
right?
Yeah.
Mostly people are awesome.
It's just a few of these Montezuma motherfuckers running around killing
everybody.
And throughout history there's been,
gee,
you know,
giant groups of people led by serial killers and that's a big part of that other
part of reality.
They're the ones who go for that job.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of this podcast called hardcore history that it's talking about
all the time.
But,
um,
I've been listening to it lately.
It's been,
uh,
talk about,
the Nazis in World War II.
And,
but it's when you,
when you go back and pay attention to some of the things that happened in
history and you see the amazing level of ruthlessness that people exhibited,
uh,
against their enemies just drew out the history of humans.
There's been groups that flared up,
whether it's the Mongols are the Nazis or you know,
the Romans are there.
This has been so many groups of ruthless people.
Now,
Joe,
I mean,
you know,
when,
when a drone flies over a village in Afghanistan or Pakistan and,
and 120 people get slaughtered.
Yeah,
it's a bit remote.
It's a bit distant.
We're not getting our hands dirty,
but people are still being killed.
Well,
it's crazy.
Children are being deprived of their parents.
Children dying.
Children are getting the names and the numbers are so skewed in,
in the favor of,
uh,
people who were the casualties that were innocent.
And there's way more people that are innocent that are getting killed by these
drones then because then they say,
well,
that's because these terrorists,
they do things in highly populated area as well.
Well then you can't do that.
You can't just say we're going to kill.
That's that is one of the most unamerican things you could ever did.
Terrible at American thing.
The idea that you could kill all these oppressed,
innocent people just to get this one bad guy.
It's patiently obviously role
and yet at the level of government,
nobody seems to have got it yet.
How wrong it is.
Yeah.
It's diffusion of responsibility and a digital technological form of warfare
form.
Yeah,
completely.
I mean,
no one's even there.
I mean this is what we can do.
Instead of doing some horrific war crimes,
we send soldiers in there to slaughter all these innocence to get these bad
people.
Instead of doing that,
which is totally unacceptable.
We'll just do it this way where you're not even really there.
Yeah.
Like seven guys sitting in a control tower playing a computer game really
well.
How about the fact they're going to give the metals?
That was one of the big things there.
They're going to give drone pilots,
metals and people are like,
what are you doing?
Like this is getting,
but no act of courage is involved.
Well,
apparently there's been new scandal where four Americans were killed and a
recent drums drone strike.
And now Obama is trying to restrict the use of drones and trying to say that
they can't be used on Americans,
but whatever we live in strange times,
we live in strange times.
Is it because our humanity has not yet caught up to our technological
capabilities that we are,
we are evolved techno technologically so much in the past several hundred years.
We've like literally change the world entirely.
But yet the tissue,
the DNA,
the,
the echoes of the past that lie in our language and in our cultures has really
not caught up by any stretch of the imagination.
Good point.
I think that's,
I think that's a good point.
We,
we've got these,
um,
we've got these incredible toys,
but we haven't learned to play with them responsibility yet.
Yeah.
We've got this barbaric mindset that's still in place to run.
Shit.
If you want to run shit,
you gotta be a fucking savage.
The mindset hasn't changed that much in the last thousand or 500 years.
But yeah,
we're hopeful.
But we are hopeful and I,
and I and I remain hopeful.
I think it's a wonderful thing to be human.
It's a great gift to be born in the human body.
We have this,
you know,
that's part of it actually is the,
what did the human predicament is the predicament of making choices between
alternatives between good and evil,
between dark and light and the world.
Our world we live in today is filled with darkness and with light.
But the one thing that all of us can do as individuals is we can make the right
choice rather than the the wrong choice.
We don't have to add to the misery in the world.
Not even one tiny fraction.
We always got the choices we make.
Those are our responsibility alone and now we cannot develop those on others.
We can't say it's the government's fault.
The choices we make are our choices.
That is the message of Iowasca isn't.
Yes.
That's the message of Ios.
That's why everybody needs it.
Yeah.
Because your choices,
your choices are yours and your choices we'll define.
Yeah.
Isn't it funny that that would be one of the single most
powerful changing elements in this,
in this culture.
If all of a sudden IOWASCA center started opening them up and we started
exploring it scientifically,
we started
as long as the content,
those centers were run by goodhearted,
paid by Goodheart,
who had the capacity to love and wanted the betterment of mankind rather than
who was seeking personal gain or personal power,
the evil ones in the Peru and where have you,
are they taking it as well?
Yeah.
So they're taking it and doing evil things once they take it,
I'm afraid.
So,
yeah.
Wow.
So you,
do you think that they're just psychopaths that got of some Iowasca
and that funny?
Can't fix that kind of crazy.
Yes.
If you,
if,
if you come to this medicine with wicked intent,
then bad things can happen.
So you really believe in the idea of entities being evil.
You believe in the,
the,
the communication of evil entities.
I think it's a,
I think it's a very interesting possibility,
which explains a lot in human history.
Demons,
demons.
I think it's a,
I think that's a simple shorthand for it,
just as just as there are also angels.
I think that the reality is much more complicated than we imagine that a,
that there are huge,
unseen realms which impact upon us in,
in important ways.
And uh,
we are interacting with them whether we like it or not.
And in certain states of consciousness that interaction can become conscious and
we can and we can gain access to those,
to those realms.
And furthermore,
um,
I would say I,
I believe ultimately in the unity of all things,
but right now in this particular learning experience that we're undergoing in a
human incarnation,
I think it's really useful that those choices exist.
What after all,
if everything was all good and,
and rosy and perfect and that were not possible to do wrong,
what could we learn from this experience of life if we don't have the
opportunity to make mistakes?
If we don't,
if we are not faced with fundamental choices,
what,
what would we benefit from in living this life in a human body?
Well,
you know,
that's one of the main arguments for computer simulation theory.
Excellent argument.
Yeah.
It's one of the main arguments is that we've got ourselves to a point where life
is fucking boring cause we've solved all the problems,
we've eliminated all the stress and conflict.
We haven't solved all the problems.
This is a computer simulation.
The life we are living that we're in the roaring twenties of the digital era.
We're in the simulation.
Yeah.
Where it's indiscernible.
What is,
it's quite possible to imagine virtual reality even in our technology today,
getting to the point where you wouldn't know that it was virtual,
where you're totally immersed in that reality and for all we now Joe,
that's exactly what you and I are.
And at the end of our lifespan,
our 70 or 80 years or however many years we get,
you know,
random element in that we're going to step out and find ourselves in a room and
when we've been where we've been playing this game all along and then we'll be
scored on what we did,
you know,
and,
and did we,
did we actually fulfill the objectives that we set out at the beginning of the
game.
With there you get there,
you get actually with that idea of a computer simulation,
do you actually get to the,
you find yourself coming full circle and meeting very ancient spiritual ideas
like that thing that I called the weighing of the,
of the soul,
the ancient Egyptian system.
That's where,
that's where you get scored on how you performed in the computer game and how
you maybe how you performed was not,
you know,
how much money you made or how much power you had.
Maybe it was really how much love you gave that was the,
that was the thing you most need it to do.
Is it possible that the,
the,
those sorta the fractal nature of reality,
um,
manifest itself in the idea of these demons being that in that you,
you must reinforce good and you must punish bad.
And the only way these dumb people ever really completely understand is if they
feel a physical manifestation of the evil that they've caused.
And that's what a demon is.
So it's just sort of a guide rail that you bump into something that's supposed
to steer you towards the positive,
the very reason why you evolve after like a psychedelic trip,
seeing the bad that you're doing,
seeing the evil as manifested as an actual being.
Yeah.
Where it's most terrifying your common enemies that you have in real life,
whether it's predators or enemies,
there are physical manifestations.
Absolutely.
So we don't,
you know,
we don't know the answer to these questions.
These are these way of touching here upon a great mystery.
Uh,
people all over the world have these experiences and report remarkably similar
encounters with entities,
either demonic or angelic.
And this has been going on throughout human culture.
And it's a feature of the psychedelic experience as well,
and we don't know what those things are.
This is,
this is just not clear.
We'll,
do they have an independent existence from us or are they part of a teaching
program that we need to encounter as you're suggesting just now?
I think they're very interesting question is to examine,
but I don't know the answer to them.
I've always had an issue with the,
the,
the possibility of archetypes to that people have already established that
archetypes that people already have in their hands so that they,
you know,
when,
when the have an abduction experience,
what you think is an abduction as parents,
you sort of fill in the blanks with whatever these entities are,
all the,
all of a sudden they become these gray guys,
a big black eyes because that's the cultural archetype that we've sort of
subscribed to and in all these stories.
Yeah.
Why do we find them painted on cave walls 25,000 years ago?
That's a good question.
It's a good question.
Which ones did we find?
Well,
particularly on the walls of,
in fact,
on a little alcove in the ceiling inside Pesh male cave in France.
There's a fantastically recognizable depiction of what we would call a gray
today.
Can you pull that up?
Okay.
How you spell column there?
The um,
the um,
uh,
the wounded man sometimes he's,
he's passionate.
L P E C h m e R,
l,
e,
passion male,
and he is peers through the body with a number of spears and he has this kind of
high domed forehead and narrow pointed Chin and just a hint of large,
dark eyes.
Do you think that these things are actually physically visiting or do you think
that there's a chemical doorway that's a open through psychedelics or through
some technology and that that's how they're appearing?
I think it's a chemical doorway.
I think that we have a,
I think we have a headend doorway inside our minds through which we can project
our consciousness into levels of reality.
I can't prove that,
but that's what I,
I think maybe maybe going on.
That's what it feels to you when you experienced this as what it feels to me
like that I mentoring,
um,
uh,
seamlessly convincing parallel world.
And again,
I want to stress the point that because you've had this experience,
this is true experiences.
If they're just a hallucination,
a byproduct of the mind that is impossible.
The prove you're still having the exact same experience.
Yeah.
You're still having the,
it's actually an experience.
So there you come back to the point we made earlier that what do you then learn
from that experience?
And if you grow in some way through that experience,
it doesn't really matter whether it's
freestanding reality or whether it's a,
you know,
something you projected.
And as we become more interconnected with our ability to communicate and our,
our,
our idea that the human race really is one gigantic super organism.
As we accept that idea more and more,
it,
it opens up a lot of other possibilities.
It opens up a lot of pot possibilities for just our overall view of things.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
This is a,
this is the,
the new,
um,
Copernican revolution that we're poised on the edge of,
you know,
at one time,
uh,
it was considered that the,
that the sun went around the earth and that all the stars revolved around the
earth and the earth was fixed and still in the center.
And then some people started having experiences or if you like finding data
which contradicted that and eventually a whole worldview was,
was thrown away.
And I think we're,
you know,
at the edge of moving into a new,
into,
into a whole new revolution about the nature of reality that it is just much
more complicated than we've imagined.
Um,
yeah,
that's a,
that's a kind of sketch of the patch male figure.
That's not the original cave painting.
And I'm afraid the only Ufos that are actually present are the ones above the
individuals had.
The other two are not there in the,
so let's go see if you can find the original one,
Jamie.
Cause I only,
it's like shit that looks like an animal to the,
you know,
who knows what.
They were really terrible at drawing to
drawing.
Some of them were,
some of the cave paintings are absolutely stunning.
I wouldn't pay for him.
I mean I would if I knew they were really old.
You'd haven't seen,
it's like some dude,
dude just came along and that was his version of a Buffalo Lake Bitch.
Yes.
You haven't seen what he's painted inside Chauvet Cave and I watched that
documentary,
the word of Herzog documentary.
I,
no,
it's amazing.
I'm joking around obviously as you can,
but still know.
I'd rather buy an Alex Gray painting.
I think it's shit.
It's cool.
Yeah.
I and I would like some frank Frazetta that's art to me.
There's no frank Frazetta on cave walls.
They didn't really,
I mean
the caves,
this is what the great experiences we can have as human beings is to go into
those painted caves and go in and silence and in darkness and just get a sense
of the atmosphere there.
Transformative spaces.
They knew something about set and setting in those times.
And of course I'm convinced they were using psychedelics.
And that was a,
the the caves in France
or caves in France.
Caves in Spain.
Yeah.
And what are the oldest ones?
Through the cave?
Very oldest is full Monte cave in Italy,
which is 35,000 years old.
Chauvet cave about 33 32,000 years old.
Uh,
they're,
they,
they're pretty,
pretty fucking Asia.
So do you think that those were people that were living in those caves
that wouldn't be making,
that artwork will never lived in those caves?
Never lived in them?
No.
No,
they didn't.
They use them as sacred spaces.
They visited them in small numbers,
often separated.
There might be an interval of 2000 years between when one group went in and when
another group went in.
So our idea of cave art as the lay person's ideas,
these cave men were inside this cave.
And then at nighttime they would light fires and draw cave art.
That's not what was,
they love it.
They never lived in those spaces.
They lived outside.
They lived in,
you know,
in portable structures like tps.
Um,
they were,
they were hunter gatherers and they use the caves as sacred spaces are,
they communicated their most profound ideas about the spirit.
So they were a lot more sophisticated than we like to believe.
I would just as sophisticated as we are.
Was there ever a time before that that we know of where they weren't,
where like the Endo talls supposedly are being,
uh,
they,
they did some cave art as well,
correct.
Yep.
This is the new discovery that some of the very oldest cave art was almost
certainly done by neanderthals.
So the neanderthal image is due for a complete rehabilitation,
uh,
very,
very sued.
Uh,
the,
the neanderthals,
the image that we have of neanderthals is completely wrong,
but there's a thing I call 6 million years of boredom,
which is,
you know,
from the last common ancestor with the chimpanzee through until,
well,
after the emergence of anatomically modern humans,
our ancestors were very dull.
Judging by what they left behind,
judging by what they produced,
they were not thinking laterally.
They were not creating the,
they were not,
they did not have spiritual concepts or ideas.
And it's rather like a light is switched on in the human brain all around the
world somewhere after a hundred thousand years ago,
um,
really 40,000 years ago,
that we get this amazing explosion of symbolic art and suddenly you recognize
that the creatures are just like us and that we are,
we are dealing with,
um,
with people we could communicate with on a,
on a,
on a symbolic level.
So something happened to our ancestors and I,
and I made this case extensively in my book,
supernatural,
that what happened to our ancestors was encounters with psychedelics.
That's what took us out of the dull and boring zone and put us into the realm of
imagination and creativity and spirit.
Well,
it's a fascinating idea and it's a weird one to dismiss because we know that the
impact of psychedelics on the mind is so astonishing.
It's very poopooed in marginalized because it's thought to be frivolous and
silly,
but that's only by people who haven't done it.
Yeah.
It's one of the weirdest
things where it's,
it's persecuted by people who really need it more than anybody.
Exactly.
I mean,
for,
for those who've never had a psychedelic experience to put down others who have
had it and to tell them that that experience is,
is wrong.
I mean,
that's like a cell a bit,
you know,
telling somebody not to have sex they celebrate has no experience of the thing
that they're talking about.
How dare they make judgments about that?
Yeah,
that's a good point.
It's strange,
but I think that,
um,
people like you that are brave enough to speak out about this,
in fact,
even write books about it,
that's,
that's the ripples that sends out this information and the universe picks it up
and the internet grabs it and duplicates it and throws it up on Twitter and then
boom,
we're off to the races and new ideas are introduced into the minds of the young
people who,
I think that's what,
what gives me up.
That's what gives me hope too.
Younger is fantastic.
Growing community of alert,
intelligent,
awake,
aware young people out there that grew up with the Internet,
grew up with the Internet and um,
that,
uh,
I'm not going to put up with all that shit any longer that comes down from a
hierarchical controlling,
dominated culture.
Boom.
Graham Hancock.
Just drop some science.
That was a beautiful conversation man.
Thank you very much.
Thank you to you got to do this more often.
I agree.
When are you back in a America?
Oh,
late October.
So if people want to buy war God they can go to amazon.co.
Dot.
UK Right.
The easiest way to do it is to go to my website.
Okay.
Graham hancock.com [inaudible] dot com.
You already have,
you have the Canadian and the UK link cause that's the two places that somebody
in Canada or Amazon UK would,
they can buy it there and hopefully even all our friends at audible or
listening,
hook it up,
bitch.
Get somebody to read it.
Come on.
I'd love to have that in my car when I'm driving around.
Um,
but I will,
I'll pick it up as well.
Support.
Frank.
Thank you sir.
Um,
and is that the original k word?
Yes,
it is.
There it is.
So you could see that high domed forehead up there could just be shitty art that
art start to see that you could see the dark guys.
Well,
what you could have,
but you know what?
It's also set up in the sky up above it.
I mean,
what is it?
Say something.
I got a three year old and she draws people.
They look exactly like that.
She's not trying to depict aliens.
She's just shitty at drawing.
This is,
you know,
it's the problem with this is is it's too,
it's too ambiguous.
It's like that's not good art.
I mean,
so I don't know what that is.
That a spider could be a spider.
It could be like a crab.
It's a,
it's a human thing in the upper left with spears pit pierced through his body.
What about that thing in the upper left?
What the hell is that thing there?
I nobody knows.
Nobody knows what he fucking shitty spider.
That guy sucked.
I hope that guy was way better at killing buffaloes.
Drugs.
A dog.
Shit to send you into the painted cave.
I think I'm joking around completely.
I mean this I'm not that impressed with,
I would like to look at it.
I'm thinking it's fascinating because it's so old as a work of art,
it's not impressive.
But as a subject matter what you know,
what is being depicted there is rather is rather interesting.
I sort of disagree and this is why I disagree because this thing in the upper
left,
it might be a spider,
shows me a really rudimentary level of replicating what they're trying to draw.
That looks like shit.
And so this looks like shit too.
I don't know what it is.
It might be a bug,
it might be a an animal.
It's like the guy sucks at drawing.
He's not that good.
So to try to attribute anything to it,
I said,
I think it will be a little disingenuous.
So those uh,
archeologists that you know that are trying to figure what this thing out is,
it just gets it man.
Same sort of image is found all over the world.
It is that the image of the gray hair,
right?
Guy Image of the,
of the theory and throat,
which is the creature that's part human and part animal informed that is found,
that is found a wall all around the world.
Often I've seen virtually identical images in the painted caves in France and in
canyons in Utah for example.
And you feel that that is directly related to psychedelic use,
the spirit world.
And I think this is related to psychedelics as well.
I think that's a painting of a vision.
Um,
and the vision might've been,
you know,
not very clear,
but,
but that's what,
that's what's being paid.
I think somebody gave her three year old a colored rock and that's what the
true,
that's my three year old draws.
I'm telling you man.
Um,
the,
the idea of the,
the morphing,
right?
If you,
if you it Google call up,
call up show v Chauvet cave images for Chauvet cave.
I want Joe to see some beautiful images.
Oh No,
I will.
I will be very impressed.
I'm just joking around and being completely joking and silly,
but you're right.
That ain't me.
That image is rudimentary.
What are the best images?
The best images,
depictions of aliens to you that you,
well,
first of all,
let me,
let me make it clear.
I don't think that the,
that we're dealing with aliens,
quote unquote great.
I'm sorry.
I agree.
I think we're dealing with a mystery.
I think we're dealing with a phenomenon and I think we as a culture or certain
members of our culture or jumping to the conclusion that creatures a bit like us
perhaps looking slightly different in very high tech craft are crossing
interstellar space.
There's beautiful picture from Chavez.
So bad I crossing interstellar space and are coming here in technology.
But I personally think,
again,
I can't prove it,
but I think it's more likely we're dealing with interdimensional contacts that
these,
that these entities are,
are not high tech aliens from a planet,
a bit like ours,
but they're coming to us from literally the other side of reality.
Well,
my unfortunate labeling aside,
um,
calling them aliens,
I meant that archetype that big that you say repeats itself over and over again
in Africa for example,
in the drag is the big mountains.
Just like that.
Is that the,
what's the best example we can pull up right now?
So we just,
I don't think you'd be able to pull this up.
No,
they don't have those images online.
You might,
you might find it.
I'm not sure thing is on the Internet.
I'm not sure I have it in my,
in my book supernatural.
But what is the best one that's
online in your opinion?
I honestly couldn't tell you.
Okay.
I just wanted to get some,
I've seen some really fascinating ones.
Um,
uh,
one crazy shaman.
The where it's a [inaudible],
it's a very strange looking creature.
He looks like it could be
Shalon Cave in Texas.
Puzzling.
Is that what it is?
And those are his,
those native American depictions.
Soundness,
yeah.
Yeah.
But then you find similar things from,
from [inaudible] in,
in Algeria.
You know,
these kind of glowing figures that seem to,
it's very easy to construe them as,
as alien visitors from,
from other planets.
So many drugs,
like whether it's Iowaska or there's other ones that have archetypes that are
built in like snakes and you know,
Jaguars.
What do you,
what do you think that is?
Do you think that's the experiences of the people that have taken it before you?
Well,
first of all,
I don't think it's that we don't know what an archetype is,
right?
It's this idea that the human brain has all these patterns and shapes just built
into it.
Archetypally but I think just as easy just as possible is that there are other
levels of reality in which entities are able to look like that shape shifting
entities that can take on many different forms that the experience is very
universal.
For example,
everyone who drinks Iowasca,
um,
pretty much everyone,
if they persist with it,
we'll encounter serpents and those serpents aren't like your everyday sip and
you know,
the 500 feet long with no miles,
the size of cars and,
and um,
richly colored and colored and patterned and,
and intelligent,
you know.
Now why is it that somebody who drinks Iowasca in Tokyo and somebody who drinks
it in New York and somebody who drinks it in the Amazon,
that they all encounter these serpent intelligence serpent entities?
Fingerless well,
I think that there's something out there which chooses to manifest in that form.
And I think that it's being witnessed just as just as if I'm three different
explorers went into the jungle and met the same previously uncontacted con
uncontacted tribe and came back and drew us images.
And they think that there is some reality to it,
but I can't prove that.
I just think that that's what's,
that's what's going on.
And I've had enough in Canada,
so like Rick Strassman's work with DMT,
which I know that you're familiar with because you presented the Dmt,
the spirit molecule documentary,
you know that a number of his volunteers in counter entities who say to them,
we're so glad you've discovered this technology,
now we can communicate with you more often.
Right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I always wonder about those trips,
whether or not that's just your imagination on hyperdrive creating these
impromptu right and proper that you should wonder about.
Yeah.
But there's also the possibility that no,
it's a,
you're communicating with something.
Yeah.
But either way,
again,
like we said,
it's the same experience.
Yeah.
Right.
You're a bad mother fucker.
Graham Hancock Bank really are.
I'm,
I'm glad I take that as a couple of other shit.
So you should,
I'm glad we're friends.
I really,
really enjoy our talks.
So one of my favorite podcasts ever.
Thank.
Thank you.
Thank you John.
It's a real pleasure to sit down with so war God people can get it.
Go to Graham hancock.com and on Twitter.
He's Graham double underscore Handcock.
Thank you and thank you to everybody that tuned into the podcast.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to hover or please go to hover.com forward slash Rogen get yourself 10%
off.
Thank you to stamps.com use the click on the microphone in the upper right hand
corner and use the code word j.
R e and thank you also to onnit.com go to o,
n n I.
T.
Use the code name,
Rogan and save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
We will be back on Monday with uh,
Dave Asprey.
A lot of people really enjoyed his first talk and he's got a lot of new
information.
I know a lot of folks who have questions about the whole bulletproof exact go to
bulletproof exec.com if you want to prepare for this and find out what the fuck
Dave Asprey is all about,
but he's a brilliant guy and we'll look forward to talking to him on Monday.
All right.
Thank you everybody.
Much love big kiss.